bonjour à toutes et à tous
mes chers collègues nous allons débuter
notre séance nous recevons cet
après-midi madame Carole Grandjean
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle madame la ministre je
vous remercie d'avoir répondu
favorablement à notre invitation qui
fait suite à de nouvelles annonces au
sujet de la réforme du lycée
professionnel nous prendrons d'ailleurs
la vie des syndicats d'enseignants sur
cette réforme le 7 juin le 4 mai dernier
le présente de la République présentait
les dispositifs de la réforme devant
permettre de faire de la voie
professionnelle une voix d'excellence
après un large processus de concertation
engagée depuis l'automne refonte de la
carte de formation lutte contre le
décrochage des élèves et renforcement
des liens entre les lycées les
entreprises devront ainsi assurer un
enseignement plus adapté aux besoins des
élèves et une insertion professionnelle
facilitée pour ces jeunes
et je souhaiterais pour ma part vous
interroger sur deux points tout d'abord
la volonté du gouvernement de moderniser
l'offre de formation afin de la rendre
plus cohérente avec des besoins et les
débouchés supposent à terme la fermeture
des formations ne menant pas
suffisamment à l'emploi dès lors je
souhaiterais savoir comment et par qui
se réévalué puis acter la suppression de
certaines filières professionnelles et
quelles perspective seront offertes au
professeur des formations concernées par
ailleurs la réforme en renforcer les
périodes de stage pour les élèves des
lycées professionnels ces stages seront
désormais indemnisés afin de valoriser
l'investissement des élèves et pourront
représenter selon les projets
professionnels jusqu'à 12 semaines
pendant l'année de terminale cette
avancée suppose identifier les
entreprises les plus à même d'encadrer
de former et de préparer à l'emploi des
lycéens concernés donc pourriez-vous
nous expliquer selon quelle modalités
les entreprises partenaires seront
sélectionnées et par quels moyens les
établissements pourront s'assurer que
l'allongement des périodes de stage
n'entraîne pas un amoindrissement de la
qualité de prise en charge des
stagiaires donc vous voyez deux
questions mais mes collègues en ont
beaucoup plus et mais madame la ministre
je vais vous donner la parole pour une
intervention liminaire et puis ensuite
la parole sera aux orateurs de groupe
merci beaucoup madame la présidente de
la commission des affaires culturelles
et de l'éducation mesdames et messieurs
les députés je suis ravie de
d'intervenir à nouveau devant votre
commission aujourd'hui pour présenter la
réforme de la du lycée professionnel
vous le savez le président de la
République a positionné publiquement le
jeudi 4 mai la réforme du lycée
professionnel comme une cause nationale
et comme l'un des grands rendez-vous de
la nation avec elle-même cette réforme
ambitieuse et décisive pour l'avenir des
jeunes des lycées professionnels de
notre pays elle se décline en trois
grands leviers le premier qui vise à
mieux accompagner chaque lycéen dans son
parcours y compris en cas de décrochage
et pour mieux prévenir ce décrochage
pendant le lycée ou après le second
levier vise à permettre un
meilleur taux d'insertion pour les
élèves et de faire du lycée
professionnel un véritable outil de
formation au service de notre économie
pour la réussite des élèves et enfin le
troisième levier et dernier levier et
essentiel puisqu'il s'agit de donner aux
équipes éducatives les moyens pour agir
vous savez j'ai déjà pu partager avec
vous le constat préoccupant qui s'est
imposé à nous à propos des lycées
professionnels et qui nous obligent à
réagir vous connaissez sans doute les
chiffres qui caractérisent la voix
professionnelle et dont nous ne pouvons
nous satisfaire les lycées
professionnels accueillent je le
rappelle chaque année un tiers des
lycéens un lycéen sur trois va au lycée
professionnel soit
621000 élèves et 64
000 apprentis pourtant elle concentre
cette voix davantage de jeunes en
difficulté qui subissent cette voie
puisqu'il ne l'a choisi ça vous alarmant
encore aujourd'hui moins d'un bachelier
professionnel sur deux parvient à
s'insérer dans l'emploi dans les six
mois qui suit l'obtention de son diplôme
je crois que nous pouvons tous convenir
ici que nous ne pouvons fermer les yeux
devant cette injustice devant cette
réalité qui est bien sûr source de
frustration pour les jeunes pour leur
famille mais aussi pour les enseignants
et les l'ensemble des équipes éducatives
il est
dommageable bien sûr pour le pays tout
entier car les filières de la voie
professionnelle permettent au lycéen de
se former dans des secteurs essentiels
pour notre économie et je pense par
exemple
l'énergie à la restauration au BTP ou au
métier du soin pour toutes ces raisons
dès sa campagne présidentielle le
président de la République c'était
engagé à réformer les lycées
professionnels trois indicateurs pour
atteindre cet objectif de meilleure
réussite des élèves et cette volonté de
valoriser la voie professionnelle comme
une filière et une voix de formation
d'excellence ont été établis celui du de
l'amélioration du taux d'inser tion
professionnelle des lycéens celui de
l'amélioration de la réussite des
poursuites d'études et celui de la lutte
contre le décrochage scolaire
vous le savez la réforme découle d'une
large consultation de l'ensemble des
parties prenantes de l'écosystème des
lycées professionnels avec qui des
échanges ont fait évoluer très
considérablement le projet initial dès
la rentrée 2022 le travail de terrain a
été mené pour concerter et bâtir
collectivement cette réforme j'ai donc
installé quatre groupes de travail
constitués des représentants des élèves
et de leurs parents des représentants
d'établissements et des académies des
partenaires sociaux des représentants
des régions qui se sont réunis pendant
plus de trois mois pour imaginer le
lycée professionnel de demain et
répondre aux difficultés qu'ils
rencontrent aujourd'hui nous avons eu
ensemble l'occasion de points d'étapes
réguliers sur l'avancement des travaux
de cette réforme le 9 janvier dernier à
l'Assemblée nationale dans le cadre d'un
débat sur la voie professionnelle puis
ici en audition devant votre commission
le 28 février dernier cette réforme elle
entrera en vigueur de manière
progressive échelonnée elle laissera la
place aux initiatives locales des lycées
professionnels pour ajuster au mieux les
projets d'établissement au profil des
élèves aux réalités du terrain c'est une
réforme globale qui vient du terrain qui
s'appliquera donc différemment d'un
lycée à l'autre avec au fond autant de
projets d'établissement et donc autant
de traduction je veux dire concrète de
la réforme que je conduis
pour autant cet objectif de réussite des
élèves au travers des indicateurs que je
citais tout à l'heure
ils seront visibles au travers de
mesures qui s'installeront dès la
rentrée 2023 et qui seront plus
pleinement atteints à la rentrée 2024 je
tiens à la rappeler ce sont des moyens
considérables qui ont été mis sur cette
réforme de du lycée professionnel et ce
de manière inédite c'est plus d'un
milliard d'euros supplémentaires par an
qui sera investi dans le lycée
professionnel et en plus de cela c'est
au fond
2100 établissements qui demain auront un
chargé de relations avec les entreprises
et donc ils seront installés dès cette
rentrée 2023 je l'ai déjà annoncé mais
je le rappelle j'ai annoncé le maintien
des moyens professeurs donc des
effectifs de professeurs à la rentrée
2023 ainsi qu'un renfort effectifs de
personnel pédagogique et de personnel
d'accompagnement notamment sur les
questions sociales je pense au CPE aux
infirmiers aux assistances sociaux et
puis c'est 2,5 milliards d'euros qui
sont mobilisables au travers de France
2030 pour accompagner le financement des
plateaux techniques de la formation des
enseignants et pour travailler à
l'attractivité et la mise en lumière de
certaines filières d'avenir pour
participer à l'effort d'orientation et
d'attractivité de des filières je dédie
cette réforme elle est ambitieuse son
contenu est dense et il
va permettre au personnel pédagogiques
de mobiliser finalement les leviers qui
correspond aux enjeux qui sont les leurs
pour favoriser la réussite des élèves je
détaillerai les trois leviers qui nous
permettront de faire de la voie
professionnelle une filière de
d'excellence le premier levier il vise à
renforcer l'accompagnement des élèves de
lycée professionnel et à lutter contre
le décrochage ce premier levier il est
fondamental et il se déploie autour de 6
mesures premièrement comme le président
de la République s'y était engagé des
stages des élèves de la voix
professionnelle qui seront gratifiés par
l'État dès la rentrée prochaine il
s'agira à la fois de motiver et de
valoriser ces élèves avec une
gratification de stage qui va de 50 à
100 euros selon les années et un élève
de lycée professionnel pourra ainsi
recevoir de l'État jusqu'à 2100 euros
pendant ces trois années de formation en
bac pro il s'agit aussi de
responsabiliser bien sûr l'élève sur ce
temps en entreprise qui concourt à sa
formation il s'agit aussi de
responsabiliser l'établissement qui doit
accompagner ce jeune pour qu'il est un
stage un PFMP en entreprise qui soit
cohérent par rapport à sa formation et
de qualité bien sûr et puis les
responsabilise bien sûr entreprises qui
accueille un jeune dont la gratification
est financée par l'État et qui doit
faire le travail de concourir avec
l'établissement à la formation de ce
jeune la deuxième mesure que je souhaite
mettre en lumière par rapport à ces
éléments de meilleure accompagnement des
fragilités scolaires et de lutte contre
les crochages c'est l'intensification de
l'accompagnement des élèves pour qu'ils
réussissent mieux au niveau scolaire à
partir de la rentrée 2024 le soutien en
petit groupe pour les élèves les plus
fragiles sera généralisé aux Français
aux mathématiques dans tous les
établissements et les lycées volontaires
pourront le mettre en place dès cette
rentrée quelle que soit la discipline
au-delà des savoirs fondamentaux les
élèves de la voix professionnelle
pourront comme leurs camarades des voix
général et technologiques choisir des
matières optionnelles dès cette rentrée
prochaine dès lors que des professeurs
volontaires s'engageront pour les
enseigner c'est notre troisième mesure
notre quatrième mesure concerne l'année
de terminale elle sera donc adaptée au
projet de l'élève et certaines épreuves
nationales du bac seront donc passées
plus tôt dans l'année à compter du bac
2025 puisqu'il s'agira de d'accompagner
les élèves qui rentrent en première à la
rentrée 2024
2023 pardon certains élèves souhaitent
s'insérer professionnellement dès
l'obtention de leur diplôme et donc nous
accompagnerons cette volonté par une
augmentation de 50% des durées de stage
et ceux qui souhaitent poursuivre des
études seront accompagnées par quatre
semaines de préparation à cette volonté
de poursuivre des études et donc quatre
semaines de cours intensifs pour leur
permettre de mieux réussir cette étape
dans leur parcours qui aujourd'hui trop
souvent et un échec un sur deux et un
élève sur deux ne réussit pas à obtenir
son diplôme et décroche avant
l'obtention de son diplôme lorsqu'il
poursuit des études je le rappelle avec
cette organisation donc on a une année
de terminale qui va poursuivre deux
objectifs le premier c'est de permettre
aux élèves de passer leur bac dans des
meilleures conditions et elle leur offre
une rampe de lancement pour la suite de
leur parcours celle qu'ils auront choisi
et celles que nous organiserons pour
mieux les accompagner
c'était jusque là clairement un chéneau
manquant et c'est selon moi
véritablement un enjeu majeur de
valorisation de la voie professionnelle
de permettre de mieux accompagner des
jeunes dans leur projet et de faire en
sorte que quel que soit leur projet on
soit en situation de les faire réussir
à présent je crois vrai tellement long
qu'on peut dire que c'est indispensable
de d'accompagner ce chemin car si le
jeune ne sait pas en entrant en lycée
professionnel qu'il peut poursuivre des
études s'il le souhaite c'est évidemment
une dévalorisation de la voix
professionnelle que nous rencontrerons
chez chacun tout comme s'il n'est pas
convaincu que nous mettrons tout en
oeuvre pour favoriser son insertion
professionnelle si elle est son choix
une autre mesure sera la création de
trois nouveaux dispositifs pour prévenir
les risques de décrochage pendant et
après le lycée je pense d'abord au
dispositif tout droit ouvert qui
ambitionne de prévenir et de
d'accompagner les situations de
décrochage en proposant très vite aux
jeunes concernés une palette de
solutions adaptées à leur situation la
détection des premiers signaux de
décrochage par les équipes éducatives
sera ici essentielle tout en
organisant la mobilisation de l'ensemble
des acteurs territoriaux susceptibles
d'aider ces jeunes à retrouver une
motivation et je pense ici notamment au
centre EPIDE aux écoles de la seconde
chance et de la deuxième chance et à
l'Agence du service civique ou encore au
micro lycée enfin tous ces dispositifs
qui existent et qui savent accompagner
des élèves en situation de décrochage et
puis on a expérimenté
dans huit académies tout droit ouvert
qui sera généralisé à la rentrée
scolaire 2023 cette véritablement un
élément fondamental de cette réforme un
deuxième dispositif de prévention des
risques de décrochage ambition emploi
sera mis en place dès la rentrée
scolaire prochaine pour aider les jeunes
qui se retrouvent sans
après les années de lycée tout en
conservant à leur statut d'élèves ces
jeunes seront donc accompagnés 4 mois
jusqu'au 31 décembre et bénéficieront
pendant cette période de stage
d'immersion dans des classes de
terminale d'un appui à la recherche
d'emploi ou d'un contrat d'apprentissage
de rencontre avec des recruteurs
véritablement pour nous l'objectif est
de ne pas laisser ce jeune sans solution
et sans accompagnement à la rentrée qui
suit l'obtention de son bac si à l'issue
de ces quatre mois ces jeunes demeurent
sans solution il se verront proposé un
contrat d'engagement jeune et enfin un
parcours de consolidation sera proposé
dès le mois de décembre aux étudiants de
première année de BTS qui
rencontre des difficultés lors de leur
BTS il s'agit d'un parcours qui sera
proposé dès cette année dans les lycées
volontaires et qui leur permettra de
consolider de savoir académiques et
méthodologiques durant quelques mois
pour cela des professeurs de lycée
professionnel engagés viendront
renforcer l'équipe pédagogique de BTS à
l'issue du conseil de classe de juin les
jeunes les plus en difficulté pourront
préparer leur BTS en trois ans et ceux
qui ont su bénéficier de cette
consolidation pourront passer
directement en secondaire
notre dernière mesure sur ce premier
grand levier et la construction de
partenariats extérieurs qui nous
permettront aussi de mieux préparer
l'insertion professionnelle des élèves
comme vous le savez l'expérimentation à
venir pro se déploie actuellement auprès
de 8000 élèves ce sont des conseillers
Pôle emploi qui les aident à rechercher
les occultes d'emploi à prendre à
identifier et à valoriser leurs
compétences et à mieux comprendre les
attentes des employeurs à venir pro sera
donc étendu progressivement à tous les
élèves en dernière année de lycée
professionnel qui souhaite s'insérer
dans l'emploi après leur diplôme la
moitié d'entre eux dès la rentrée
prochaine et tous à compter de la
suivante des partenariats avec les
principales associations dédiées à
l'accompagnement des jeunes permettront
par ailleurs de déployer le dispositif
un jeune un mentor dans les lycées
professionnels à partir de la prochaine
rentrée scolaire c'est véritablement
pour moi
levier d'émancipation il permettra à
tous les élèves d'être accompagnés
soutenus par un mentor s'il le souhaite
des 2025 dans tous les lycées
professionnels et donc pour tous les
lycéens volontaires
le second levier vise à faire du lycée
professionnel une solution au grand défi
de notre économie c'est la souveraineté
industrielle numérique et énergétique
qui ne se conquestrit concrétisera pas
sans cette souveraineté des compétences
et donc on nous devons adapter le lycée
professionnel pour que dès aujourd'hui
il prépare une offre de formation qui
prépare au grand défi de demain et qui
prépare ses jeunes à leur avenir
professionnel nous aurons donc une
rénovation en profondeur d'un quart des
diplômes d'ici à la rentrée 2025 je
tiens à rappeler que certains diplômes
ont en effet été conçus il y a plus de
20 ans et que seulement 30 diplôme sur
550 sont rénovés chaque année et c'est
donc véritablement une accélération
cette révision que nous visons pour
mieux s'adapter aux transformations des
métiers et en prenant compte des grandes
transitions celles notamment écologiques
numériques et démographique
c'est le changement de l'offre madame la
Présidente de formation des lycées
professionnels nous souhaitons accélérer
l'évolution des formations proposées en
lycée professionnel en les adaptant aux
enjeux de l'économie en fermant des
formations qui mènent insuffisamment à
l'employé à la poursuite d'études
l'objectif est clair le président de la
République l'a rappelé lors de l'annonce
de cette réforme fermée d'ici la rentrée
2026 toutes les formations qui n’ouvrent
ni perspective d'emploi ni possibilité
suffisante de poursuites d'études
réussis c'est là aussi un engagement que
nous devons prendre vis-à-vis de ces
jeunes dès lors que nous savons que ces
opportunités là n'existent pas
transformer la carte des formations est
une opération certes difficile même
lorsqu'on constate une insertion
professionnelle objectivement médiocre
après l'obtention du diplôme nous aurons
donc des mesures pour accompagner cette
réforme des moyens seront mobilisés
notamment via le plan France 2030 pour
cofinancer avec les régions dont c'est
la compétence le renouvellement des
plateaux techniques mais aussi formé les
professeurs ces 2,5 milliards d'euros
qui seront mobilisés à cet effet pour
accompagner cette transition aujourd'hui
déjà des formations ouvre et ferme
chaque année il s'agit d'accélérer ce
processus et d'accompagner mieux ses
ouvertures de formation c'est création
de plateaux techniques et cette
formation des enseignants nous mettrons
en place des outils de pilotage pour
mettre en visibilité mieux mesurer les
taux d'insertion et les taux de
poursuite d'études en formation et ce
formation par formation pour accompagner
les établissements dans la prise de
décision les propositions qui pourra
faire en matière d'évolution de leur
offre de formation et sur lesquels nous
pourrons bien sûr les accompagner je
crois véritablement que nous pouvons et
bien que nous soyons tous sensibles aux
interrogations que peuvent susciter ces
transformations
nous pouvons tous convenir que nous
pouvons nous satisfaire de la situation
actuelle que dès lors que nous savons
que des formations n'ouvrent pas de
perspective de réussite ni d'insertion
professionnelle ni de poursuite d'études
réussie nous ne pouvons accepter le
statut quo nous allons donc organisé et
ce dans une philosophie aussi de
promesses républicaine respectée des
propositions de qualité qui ouvre à la
fois possibilité de possibilités
d'insertion professionnelle mais aussi
de poursuites d'études et j'insiste
beaucoup sur ces deux options là enfin
nous allons créer des formations de
spécialisation post-bac pro en cohérence
avec les entreprises locales et les
enjeux économiques c'est une modalité
qui est très attendue par les
entreprises qui permet au lycéen de
parfaire leur formation dans leur
domaine pour multiplier les chances
d'être embauchée et on constate très
clairement sur les spécialités déjà
développées une augmentation de plus 20
points du taux d'insertion
on voit que le plus souvent elles sont
en apprentissage et elles permettent au
fond de bien préparer l'insertion et de
débuter sa vie professionnelle avec une
expérience en entreprise et nous allons
donc passer de 4500 actuellement
formation de spécialisation à 20000
d'ici à la rentrée 2026 et enfin bien
que les élèves de lycée professionnel
alterne court et stage en entreprise il
ne les rend pas toujours facile de
trouver un stage souvent faute de réseau
professionnel un bureau des entreprises
sera donc créé dans chaque lycée
professionnel dès la rentrée prochaine
il permettra aux entreprises de vos
territoires de venir facilement proposer
des stages aux jeunes et à votre lycée
de les prospecter davantage pour
proposer des stages de qualité aux
élèves et en pleine cohérence avec leur
formation créer un bureau des
entreprises dans chaque lycée
professionnel dans le but de mettre en
place des partenariats avec les acteurs
du territoire d'organiser des temps de
stage d'alternance ou de contribuer aux
démarches d'orientation information
insertion des publics accueillis quels
sont les objectifs de ces bureaux des
entreprises le troisième levier vise à
donner aux personnels éducatives des
moyens inédits pour se saisir de la
réforme aujourd'hui le professeur de
lycée professionnel n'est pas valorisé à
la hauteur de son engagement auprès de
ses élèves souvent plus fragiles
qu'ailleurs demain il sera donc mieux
formé davantage reconnu pour la
diversité des missions qu'il exerce et
de son engagement au service de la
réussite des élèves ainsi des la rentrée
prochaine les professeurs en lycées
professionnels volontaire pourront
exercer de nouvelles missions rémunérées
favorisant la réussite et un meilleur
accompagnement des élèves ils pourront
par exemple aider les élèves en
difficulté soutenir leurs projets par du
tutorat participer à la lutte contre
décrochage disposer dispenser des
matières optionnelles ou de
spécialisation faire des remplacements
de courte durée
en soutenant le lien contre tient le
lycée avec son tissu économique via des
actions de découverte des métiers etc
chaque professeur engagé pourra
prétendre à une valorisation une
valorisation salariale pouvant aller
jusqu'à 7500 euros brut annuels soit 560
euros net mensuels je souhaite également
que les nouveaux chefs d'établissement
de lycée professionnel soit mieux
accompagnés lors de leur prise de
fonction et à cet effet la formation des
personnels éducatifs sera repensée par
la création d'une formation pour les
nouveaux chefs d'établissements pour une
prise de fonction rapide mais aussi pour
une prise de fonction adaptée à la
réalité des lycées professionnels une
formation sera également évidemment
dispensée pour ceux déjà en poste ainsi
que une formation pour les professeurs
qui bénéficieront davantage de formation
continue
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
j'ai souhaité prendre le temps avec vous
de détailler toutes les mesures d'une
réforme globale
multidimensionnelle à la hauteur de
cette cause nationale qui consiste à
faire du lycée professionnel de demain
un vrai tremplin de réussite une fierté
pour ses élèves et les professeurs ainsi
que toutes les équipes et pédagogiques
qui enseignent une voix choisie je me
permets d'insister là dessus une voix de
réussite et d'excellence je vous
remercie
merci mesdames la ministre pour ces
précisions mais maintenant vous allez
être sous le feu des questions de mes
collègues et nous allons commencer par
Christophe Marion pour le groupe
Renaissance
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre tout d'abord je tiens à vous
remercier au nom du groupe renaissance
de votre présence à nos côtés alors même
que les annonces concernant la réforme
des lycées professionnels continuent à
susciter des interrogations et c'est
bien normal même si j'ai pu constater à
travers des débats ou des rencontres
avec des enseignants qu'elles avaient
déjà répondu à certaines inquiétudes qui
avaient pu naître tout au long du
travail de concertation qui a été initié
depuis l'été dernier à mesure de vos
déplacements comme en région Centre-Val
de Loire la semaine dernière de vos
annonces des annonces du président de la
République le contenu de cette réforme
attendu des lycées professionnels c'est
affiné nombreux sont ceux qui saluent
l'importance de l'effort financier
annoncé donnant ainsi corps à cette
ambition affichée de faire de la voie
professionnelle une voix d'excellence
nous savons désormais camilliard d'euros
sera investi chaque année dans les
lycées professionnels pour un meilleur
accompagnement une meilleure insertion
des lycéens comme vous l'avez précisé ce
milliard d'euros permettra de financer
les gratifications de stage des lycéens
jusqu'à 2100 euros de gratification par
élève sur trois ans les 80 informations
d'avenir annoncée pour la rentrée 2023
ou encore le pacte pour les professeurs
des lycées professionnels cette
enveloppe aidera aussi à la création des
2100 bureaux des entreprises ou à
l'ouverture de 20000 places de
spécialisation elle financera également
la création des nouveaux dispositifs
pour prévenir le décrochage scolaire
tout droit ouvert ambition emploi et
parcours de consolidation pourriez-vous
madame la ministre nous préciser la
manière dont se financement a été estimé
avez-vous par exemple une idée du nombre
d'enseignants qui seraient prêts à
s'investir dans les nouvelles missions
prévues par le pacte dit autrement ce
milliard sera-t-il suffisant pour
couvrir les différentes dépenses
envisagées par la mise en place de la
réforme vous avez également annoncé
qu’un financement de 2 milliards et demi
d'euros étaient prévus dans le cadre de
France 2030 pour accélérer la
transformation des formations proposées
par les lycées professionnels
pouvez-vous nous préciser selon quelles
modalité et avec quel partenaire c'est
fond pourront être mobilisés je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député pour
le rassemblement national Roger judo
les formes du lycée professionnel ne
manquent ni d'ambition ni de moyens le
groupe rassemblement national sait
reconnaître ce qui relève d'une volonté
réelle d'améliorer les choses à cet
égard sa ligne de conduite est constante
mais si votre réforme est acceptable
vous pouviez vous deviez la consolider
dans au moins trois domaines qui sont le
corps même de votre entreprise
premièrement la maîtrise des
fondamentaux vous parlez à ce sujet
d'anticiper mais en l'occurrence
n'anticipation
uttée de s'assurer au collège que nul
l'élève notre en seconde sans maîtriser
les fondamentaux ensuite vous indiquez
qu'à la rentrée 2023 les cours de remise
à niveau en petit groupe seront assurés
par les établissements volontaires si
c'est urgent est nécessaire cela doit
être obligatoire et surtout il
semblerait que ses cours doivent être
assurés dans le cadre du pacte par des
professeurs rémunérés en heures
supplémentaires là encore si c'est
urgent est nécessaire cela doit être
prévu dans les obligations
réglementaires de service des
professeurs deuxièmement le bureau des
entreprises le mentorat le bac + 1
tout va très bien nous estimons
cependant en matière d'insertion
professionnelle que les lycées
professionnels doivent parler doivent
passer pardon d'une obligation de moyens
à une véritable obligation de résultats
car il s'agit selon nous de la mission
première des professionnels l'insertion
troisièmement le renforcement durant 4
semaines pour les futurs BTS les cours
optionnels etc l'insertion
professionnelle ou la poursuite d'études
supérieures pour les bacheliers
professionnels ne sont envisageables
avec succès que si ces jeunes disposent
d'une solide culture générale il
convient donc selon nous de renforcer
l'enseignement général du cycle terminal
maîtrise vérifier de l'anglais cours de
philosophie et d'épistémologie des Arts
et Métiers histoire économie par exemple
au total donc cette réforme souffre à
nos yeux d'une imperfection qui n'a rien
à simple détail elle repose pour
l'essentiel sur les actes professionnels
qui doivent être assurés en Suisse du
service par des professeurs volontaires
invités à gagner vous le rappeliez
jusqu'à 7500 euros par mois par an
pardon de plus dans ce cas
la chute quand même ceci rend votre
projet très fragile au regard des enjeux
qui s'attachent à une réforme d'ampleur
du professionnelle je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député pour aider
Philippe Paul Vanier merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre
suppression de poste reconversion forcée
des PLP fermeture de section sous
statues scolaire au profit de
l'apprentissage vous ne proposez pas de
réformer le lycée professionnel vous
préparez son démantèlement après
Blanquer qui a des professionnels
l'année de seconde vous amputez et
désorganisé celle de terminale en 15 ans
la droite que vous incarnez aura fait
passer le bac pro de 4 à une année de
spécialisation professionnelle cette
entreprise de décalification n'a pas de
précédent elle annonce une perte de
savoir irréparable dont nous paierons le
prix collectivement elle fragilisera les
futurs salariés en diminuant leur niveau
de maîtrise professionnelle votre
politique est doublement coupable
coupable vis-à-vis de la jeunesse
populaire de notre pays à l'assignation
sociale vous ajoutez le déterminisme
territorial en soumettant son avenir au
seul besoin immédiat des patronales
locaux vous projetez ainsi d'ouvrir des
bureaux des entreprises au sein même des
lycées en contravention complète avec le
principe de neutralité du service public
qui interdit tout prosélythisme marchand
au sein des établissements scolaires
coupable votre politique l'est également
vis-à-vis de notre avenir commun la
crise climatique est là elle exige de
faire bifurquer nos modes de production
dans l'industrie l'énergie le bâtiment
les métiers de la mer le lycée
professionnel pourrait être un
formidable levier de transition mais en
soumettant l'offre de formation aux
intérêts privés vous empêcher tout
pilotage planifier tourner vers la
satisfaction de nos besoins d'intérêt
général en cela votre projet s'encastre
dans la politique d'un gouvernement qui
a annoncé il y a quelques jours se
résoudre à accompagner une hausse de 4
degrés du climat d'ici 2100
je ne vous intéresse donc pas sur les
détails de votre projet de destruction
après 11 49-3 en 11 mois je n'ai qu'une
question laissez-vous notre assembler
légiférer ou entendez-vous une nouvelle
fois imposée sans la soumettre au vote
des députés votre politique au pays
merci monsieur le député pour Alexandre
portier pour les républicains
alexandre-portier
la réforme du lycée pro que vous
défendez de laisse une drôle
d'impression drôle d'impression parce
qu'on dirait que vous la faites
contraint et forcé comme une case à
cocher pour avoir bonne conscience pas
davantage drôle d'impression aussi parce
que c'est très forme ça ne creux on a
une liste de mesures certaines
intéressantes mais à la fin aucune
ambition globale et en fait le lycée
professionnel est toujours vu comme un
problème au sein de l'éducation
nationale et non pas comme une solution
pour notre pays le signe c'est qu'il
aura fallu six ans pour que l'on
entendent enfin le gouvernement sur le
lycée pro et à la fin force est de
constater que votre réforme ne convainc
pas les acteurs sur le terrain est-il
audible des parents et donne
l'impression d'une véritable
méconnaissance du lycée professionnel
lui-même une méconnaissance colère
d'abord parce qu'aujourd'hui la réalité
c'est qu'on doit pas laisser
professionnelle par hasard mais par
défaut le lycée pro c'est le hier soir
de l'éducation nationale dépotoirs même
dit un enseignant en colère et puis il y
a de mes connaissances sociologiques
surtout il faut arrêter la langue de
bois et sortir de cette hypocrisie
générale dans laquelle on est depuis
trop longtemps la vérité c'est que le
lycée pro c'est le lycée des prolos tout
simplement ici pas pedia il veut
renforcer la mixité scolaire commencez
déjà par la construire au lycée pro
aujourd'hui les CSP+ fuient le lycée pro
et la vraie révolution du lycée
professionnel c'est pas de saupoudrer
les pansements c'est pas d'organiser son
démantèlement la vraie révolution du
lycée pro c'est d'en faire la voie
royale celle où l'on se battra pour
aller une bonne réforme du lycée
professionnel ce sera une réforme qui
ferait dire un ministre ou un député
c'est ça que je veux pour mon enfant
est-ce le cas avec votre réforme je ne
crois pas rémunérer les stages comme
vous le proposez ne changera absolument
rien ce n'est pas cela qui attirera les
meilleurs dans cette voie la seule chose
qui peut attirer les meilleurs dans
cette voie et donc tirer toute la
filière vers le haut c'est l'excellence
la rigueur l'exigence pourquoi madame la
ministre ne portez-vous pas la même
exigence pour nos lycées pro
que pour nos classes de prépa pour nos
ingénieurs pour nos médecins pour nos
juristes
merci Monsieur député pour les
démocrates Estelle pollest
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre lors de son déplacement à
Saintes le 4 mai dernier le président de
la République a donné une traduction
concrète à son engagement de faire de
l'enseignement professionnel une cause
nationale
cet objectif est vital en effet non
seulement pour nos 180 000 élèves qui
obtiennent le bac professionnel chaque
année mais aussi pour la France et ses
objectifs de réindustrialisation de
transition numérique et énergétique pour
citer trois défis majeurs que notre pays
doit relever
dans cette perspective le budget d'un
milliard d'euros par an annoncé et
porteur d'espoir et on ne peut que se
féliciter également qu'une gratification
soit mise en oeuvre de septembre qui
permettra de valoriser et de récompenser
le travail des élèves de les aider
financièrement et de contribuer à leur
donner davantage confiance en eux et en
leur capacité
madame la ministre au-delà des 12
mesures annoncées pour donner un nouveau
souffle au bac professionnel j'ai deux
questions à vous poser
d'abord la réforme annoncée touche le
lycée professionnel mais elle ne
comprend pas les autres filières
filières de la voie professionnelle
quand visage vous par exemple pour
élever le niveau de compétences des 160
000 élèves qui obtiennent un cap chaque
année notamment pour faciliter leur
insertion dans l'entreprise
ensuite c'est mon second point
aucune mesure Visante à augmenter
l'attractivité des filières
professionnelles n'a vraiment produit
des faits jusqu'à présent
ne pensez-vous pas que faire de la
filière professionnelle une voix
complète jusqu'au Master professionnel
serait la solution pour la rendre
vraiment attractive et ne plus entendre
qu'elle est une voix de garage voire de
relégation je vous remercie merci madame
la députée pour les socialistes
apparentés Fatiha que le hachis oui
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre
formez les mesures qui composeront votre
réforme du lycée professionnel et il est
clair que notre vision de l'enseignement
professionnel diffère de la vôtre les
élèves en lycée professionnel sont avant
tout des élèves et non des salariés très
bon marché nous nous demandons
d'ailleurs pourquoi il serait désormais
rémunéré par l'État et non par les
entreprises employeuses pour nous ce ne
sont pas les temps en entreprise qui
doivent être augmentées mais le temps en
classe à la fin de leur cursus chaque
élève doit pouvoir faire le choix entre
l'entrée dans le monde professionnel et
la poursuite d'études
plus le temps de classe est diminué au
profit du temps de rendre entreprise
plus la poursuite d'études vous le savez
devient compliqué aujourd'hui je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur la
carte des formations que vous souhaitez
revisiter
le ministre papendia a annoncé la
fermeture de 80 filières premièrement
pouvez-vous nous préciser quels seront
les critères précis retenus pour décider
de la fermeture de telle ou telle
filière
pouvez-vous nous rassurer quant au fait
que cette décision ne sera pas prise
uniquement sur la base du taux d'emploi
constaté qui serait inférieur autour
d'emplois attendus comme sur la
plateforme insère le jeune les
départements où le tour d'emploi sont
les plus faibles comme mon département
la Seine-Saint-Denis verront-ils la
quasi-totalité des filières tertiaires
supprimées enfin Madame la Ministre
avez-vous évalué avec votre
administration le nombre d'enseignants
concernés par la suppression de filières
qui devront se réorienter à la suite de
cette réforme
qu'elle sort sera réservé aux
enseignants contractuels et aux
enseignants des matières
professionnelles à long terme je vous
remercie merci madame la députée pour
horizon et apparentés Jérémy Patrier
létus merci madame la Présidente je vous
remercie de venir présenter devant notre
commission la réforme du lycée
professionnel et je voudrais vous dire
au nom des députés du groupe horizon
l'importance que nous accordons à
l'enseignement professionnel qui
constitue et ça a été rappelé par mes
collègues une voix d'excellence pour nos
jeunes la semaine dernière en faisant
visiter l'Assemblée nationale à une
classe de terminale de lycée
professionnel de ma circonscription je
constatais une nouvelle fois qu'une
partie des élèves avait choisi cette
voie par défaut alors même que cette
formation comporte de nombreux débouchés
et offrent des horizons vont pas donner
d'expression enthousiasmant nous ne
pouvons nous satisfaire de cette
situation qui entraîne de trop nombreux
décrochage la voie professionnelle doit
être une voie choisie vous l'avez
rappelé lors de votre propos liminaire
votre réforme est ambitieuse elle
comprend plusieurs actes je voudrais
insister sur la nécessité de renforcer
l'image de cette enseignement aux yeux
de nos jeunes et de leurs familles pour
revaloriser ces filières pour favoriser
leur attractivité pour répondre à
l'évolution des besoins de l'économie
nous devons faire du lycée professionnel
un acteur central notre système éducatif
dès maintenant nous devons penser à
adapter l'offre aux grandes mutations de
notre temps je pense à la transition
écologique au défi posé par les
nouvelles technologies telles que
l'intelligence artificielle pour faire
évoluer cette offre de formation vous
prévoyez de rénover en profondeur un
quart des diplômes existants et de
démultiplier le nombre annuel
d'ouverture et de fermeture de formation
pouvez-vous nous expliquer en détail
comment se feront ses choix stratégiques
d'ouverture et de fermeture de cursus
combien de temps a l'avance les futurs
élèves et leurs familles seront en
seront informés comment choisirez-vous
les filières à ouvrir et à fermer vous
pouvez vous aussi nous assurer que dans
les territoires ruraux comme le mien les
fermetures de formation n'auront pas
pour conséquence des fermetures de
classe mais conduiront bien à
l'ouverture d'un équivalent de place sur
le même territoire il est en effet
primordial de maintenir l'offre dans nos
territoires ruraux pour leur permettre
de rester ou de redevenir des bassins
d'emploi j'aimerais vous alerter en une
seconde sur la situation des personnels
de direction vous avez indiqué qu'aucun
enseignant le poste d'enseignant serait
supprimé on sera-t-il de même pour les
personnes de direction c'est pas tout à
fait le cas dans un lycée professionnel
de masse circonscription je vous
remercie merci Monsieur député pour
écologiste nupes jean-claudeau merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
je m'adresse à vous mais les réponses
appartiennent en partie au président
Macron qui a repris la main sur la
réforme avec la méthode et l'empathie
que nous lui connaissons réforme qui va
bien au-delà de nos craintes le milliard
annoncé comme la preuve irréfutable de
votre volonté d'engager des moyens
inédits n'est qu'une part des sommes
colossales dont la voix professionnelle
a été spolié littéralement dépossédé
pendant des années cette sous-exécution
scandaleuse et systématique des budgets
votés dans le programme enseignement
scolaire 141 qui servait tous les ans à
renflouer la voie générale de près de 5
30 millions 2018 à plus de 700 millions
d'euros en 2022 j'attends d'ailleurs les
explications de monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale à ce sujet pour
revenir l'actualité malgré le mirobolant
pacte proposé les syndicats les
syndicats répondent unanimement non
parce que les professeurs ne sont pas
dupes et voit bien que vous tentez
d'acheter leur adhésion à la réforme
dont l'idée majeure nous le savons
consiste à trouver l'adéquation entre
les besoins de main d'oeuvre des
entreprises et la manne que représente
le tiers des lycéens et lycéennes de
France les bureaux des entreprises au
sein des LP seront de simples bureaux de
placement ou les choix d'orientation se
feront plus en fonction des besoins du
tissu économique local que en fonction
des envies aspiration des élèves
personne n'est du la ficelle est même
tellement grosse co LP mono de
Noisy-le-Sec des parents d'élèves me
disaient qu'il était évident qu'on
privait un peu plus leurs enfants d'un
avenir ouvert et désirable
car Le Rheu horizon sera restreint à
leur lieu de vie pour quelques filières
certes attractives combien de
perspectives de déboucher très limités
ailleurs à quel moment le besoin des
entreprises prime-t-il sur celui de nos
enfants qui auront encore moins l'école
encore moins d'égalité et encore moins
d'émancipation à quel moment avez-vous
choisi de revenir à une société où
l'élève et par extension le travailleur
ne serait perçu que comme une machine à
produire ne répondant qu'à un besoin
productiviste sur un tableau Excel et à
quel moment avez-vous décidé de détruire
le lycée professionnel et de creuser
ainsi encore plus les injustices
sociales
merci monsieur le député pour GDR nups
soumiaboroa
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues même si je
partage en grande partie votre constat
il faut une réforme pour viser
l'excellence sans laisser
professionnelle mais celle que vous
proposez ne me convient absolument pas
je souhaite d'abord affirmer que les
lycées professionnels n'ont pas vocation
à devenir des agences d'intérim en effet
la réforme des lycées professionnels
présentés par Emmanuel Macron en mai
dernier comme celle datant de 2022 signe
l’abandon d'avoir une jeunesse bien
formée professionnellement et doté d'un
bagage culturel lui permettant d'exercer
pleinement sa citoyenneté cette réforme
est un renoncement de la mission
éducatrice au profit d'une complète
soumission logique du marché une main
d'oeuvre gratuite pour le patronat et
une formation réduite à des tâches
précises dictées par les entreprises en
Seine-Saint-Denis plus de 18000 élèves
sont scolarisés en lycée professionnel
ceci compte 3% d'enfants de cadres
contre 26% lycée général et
technologique à votre avis pourquoi
les élèves des classes populaires seront
donc les premiers touchés par cette
réforme qui dans les faits les
pousseront à choisir leurs filières en
fonction des besoins locaux et non en
fonction de leur ambition ou de leurs
projets professionnels cela sans compter
toutes les difficultés qu'on ces élèves
encore mineurs à trouver des stages dans
l'émission sont souvent bien éloignées
de leur formation cette réforme plonge
également la communauté éducative dans
l’incertitude ainsi le lycée Jean Moulin
de au Blanc-Mesnil et Arthur Rimbaud à
La Courneuve se sont mobilisés pour
protester contre la fermeture de ces
filières dite à faible insertion
obligeant le corps enseignant à se
reconvertir le lycée professionnel
pourtant a lieu essentiel pour former à
des métiers capables de répondre à de
nouveaux enjeux transition
environnementale et énergétique et
industrialisation ou encore à tous les
métiers du service à la personne ainsi
madame la ministre madame la ministre
que comptez-vous mettre en œuvre afin de
garantir au lycéens un avenir choisi et
non dicté que par la le marché du
travail je vous remercie merci madame la
députée pour le groupe ulotte Stéphane
Lenormand
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je ne répondrai pas un certain
nombre de d'inquiétudes qui ont été
exposées par par les collègues je ferai
simplement une première remarque c'est
que vous avez dans le détail des mesures
parlées de la prise en charge de
l'accompagnement avec 4 mois pour dans
la suite des bacheliers et un dispositif
de consolidation en première année de
BTS je crois que là on a la preuve que
au-delà de la réforme que vous portez
qui est importante pour notre pays il y
a peut-être des moyens qui s'en mettent
plus en amont pour ne pas avoir à mettre
en place ce genre d'intervention je me
concentrer pour ma part de de vous
interpeller sur la dimension ultramarine
de de cette réforme parce que nous avons
naturellement dans nos territoires
ultramarins une diversité de situations
une insularité des différences de statut
et je me contenterai donc de cette
approche ultramarine aujourd'hui la
première donc vous entendez renforcer la
place de l'entreprise dans la formation
on peut le concevoir mais vous n'êtes
pas sans savoir que le tissu économique
des Outre-mer est un peu différent qu'il
y a beaucoup de petites entreprises
est-ce que vous avez étudié les
capacités de tous les marchés à
assimiler cette évolution notamment en
augmentant le nombre d'heures de
formation et
objectif et naturellement d'assurer le
même encadrement qu'en métropole
toujours dans cette modification des
cartes de formation qui doit se faire en
lien avec les métiers d'avenir qui se
préciseront dans le cadre de l'appel
individation d'intérêt compétences et
métiers d'avenir de France de 2030
madame la ministre est-ce que une carte
des métiers d'avenir et de formation est
étudiée spécifiquement pour les
territoires ultramarins qui ont des
stades de développement et des besoins
qui peuvent être extrêmement différents
même chose en termes d'emploi du temps
pour les élèves madame la ministre vous
savez que la mobilité c'est une réelle
préoccupation dans un certain nombre de
territoires et
inquiets que cette nouvelle organisation
finalement
complexe pour entre les temps scolaires
et les temps de formation est-ce que
vous avez eu aussi un certain nombre de
retours des différents outre-mer sur ces
situations et enfin un collègue a évoqué
cette nouvelle carte pourra amener un
certain nombre de
suppression de poste que se passera-t-il
pour ces enseignants ultramarins et qui
n'auront peut-être pas forcément de
trouver des opportunités dont le
territoire d'à côté merci merci monsieur
le député madame la ministre c'est à
vous pour cette première salle de
question merci mille fois attendez je
reprends les petits dans l'ordre
monsieur le député Christophe Marion
vous m'avez posé effectivement un
certain nombre de questions au fond
aujourd'hui l'État consacre
4,9 milliards d'euros sur l'enseignement
professionnel cette réalité des moyens
je le redis elle a été maintenue pour la
rentrée 2023 notamment
euh en terme d'effectif d'enseignant
pour que en dépit de la baisse
démographique nous maintenions un effort
considérable sur le volume d'enseignant
pour accompagner au mieux ces jeunes et
donc augmenter le taux d'encadrement
pour ces jeunes et à compter de 2024
d'État investi plus d'un milliard
d'euros supplémentaires par an avec donc
chaque année un investissement en plus
sur le lycée professionnel pour
accompagner ces transformations je me
permets de le d'insister dessus parce
que on m'a demandé s'ils étaient pour
une fois si c'était effectivement dans
le cadre d'un plan non c'est une
augmentation du budget annuel pour les
lycées professionnels et qui donc
s'inscrit de manière complètement
inédite et dans la durée pour
accompagner cette transformation c'est
très significatif c'est une augmentation
de 20% du budget et donc on peut dire
que ces moyens supplémentaires
sont le reflet de l'importance qu'on
accorde au lycée professionnel et de
notre volonté de faire de la voie
professionnelle une voix de choix cette
voix de choix et sa compagne pardon des
crédits qui vient financer bien sûr le
versement de la gratification des des
stages des allocations de stage mais
aussi la rémunération des missions
complémentaires faites par les
professionnels volontaires et c'est donc
bien sûr ce qu'accompagnera notamment ce
milliard d'euros supplémentaires mais il
financera également l'ouverture des
lycées professionnels à des partenariats
extérieurs je pense par exemple à la
disposition à venir pro que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure en partenariat avec
France travail au déploiement de un
jeune un mentor puisque je souhaite que
chaque jeune puisse avoir un mentor s'il
le souhaite d'ici à 2025 il concernera
aussi le financement du car des diplômes
qui encore une fois peuvent être rénovés
pour mieux accompagner l'évolution des
métiers qui trop souvent n'ont pas fait
l'objet de révision des contenus de
diplômes c'est aussi le développement de
compétences sociales et comportementales
vous savez ces formations profanes qui
visent à mieux accompagner selon des
modalités pédagogiques plus adaptées
aussi dans les jeunes dans leur
diversité et donc dans leur diversité de
besoins à cet effort inédit je le
rappelle c'est aussi la revalorisation
socle des enseignants la même pour tous
les enseignants c'est également 700 ETTP
effectifs temps plein supplémentaires
dédié la voix professionnelle
issue de la non-saturation du plafond
d'emploi de 2022 c'est aussi un soutien
à la transformation des cartes de
formation professionnelle massif et dans
la durée via l'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt compétences et métiers
d'avenir dans le cadre du Plan France
2030 qui est donc doté de 2,5 milliards
d'euros et qui permettra de rénover les
plateaux techniques des lycées
professionnels pour former également les
professeurs et promouvoir de nouvelles
filières souvent méconnues par les
jeunes parce que nouvelle et parce que
souvent pas dans leur dans leur champ de
connaissances on aura au fond une
estimation dès la rentrée prochaine du
nombre d'enseignants qui seront
volontaires dans le cadre du Pacte nous
souhaitons néanmoins qu'il y en ait
beaucoup parce que pour déployer
l'ensemble de ces missions qu'elle soit
aussi bien éducative au sens de
l'accompagnement des difficultés
scolaires et de la lutte contre le
décrochage qu'elle soit éducatives dans
le sens du lien que nous souhaitons
faire avec
l'enseignement supérieur et la poursuite
d'études ou qu'elles soient éducative
dans le lien avec les enjeux économiques
nous avons besoin de cette mobilisation
des enseignants donc nous espérons
qu'effectivement il s'engageront
pleinement dans l'ensemble de ces
missions encore une fois adaptées selon
les les lycées les élèves et leurs
territoires selon le projet finalement
de leur établissement
sur la question de Monsieur judo je vous
remercie d'avoir eu des propos positifs
envers cette réforme et j'ai bien
compris les points de précision que vous
appeliez et donc je vais essayer de
revenir là-dessus au fond cette maîtrise
des enseignements fondamentaux vous avez
bien sûr raison il s'agit de les
travailler aussi en amont c'est ce que
nous avons fait lors de la précédente
mandature lors du précédent quinquennat
notamment au travers de l'obligation de
scolarisation des trois ans car on sait
qu'effectivement un certain nombre
d'élèves démarre lorsque la réalité avec
300 mots de connaissances alors que
d'autres au même âge démarre avec 2500
mots dans leur dans leur tissu de
connaissances donc on voit que les
inégalités démarrent très jeunes et
qu'il faut travailler très jeune à les
lycées c'est donc là le sens de
l'obligation des trois ans de
scolarisation mais c'est aussi ce qui a
été fait autour du dédoublement dans les
grandes sections CP CE1 pour les repérer
plus pour viser à se rattrapage
d'inégalités notamment dans des
territoires plus fragiles c'est aussi ce
plafonnement à 24 pour les plus petites
classes qui a été mise en place par le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse c'est aussi une manière
d'accompagner mieux ces jeunes de leur
diversité et selon leurs besoins c'est
également le projet de réforme qui est
portée par le ministre Papen DIY autour
de la réforme du collège pour
accompagner cette marche vers la 6ème
qui est parfois difficile et qu'il faut
pouvoir accompagner donc au fond moi je
tiens encore une fois à le dire c'est
pas du fait des des professeurs de
lycées professionnels des équipes
éducatifs que ces élèves-là sont en
difficulté c'est bien sûr une réponse
systémique qu'il faut apporter mais
c'est aussi finalement au lycée
professionnel qu'il faut pouvoir y
répondre je rappelle juste ce chiffre
les élèves en lycée professionnel ont eu
en moyenne 7 sur 20 au brevet alors que
quand ils sont enseignement général et
technologique ils ont eu 11,7 de moyenne
sur 20 à ce même brevet c'est dire
qu'effectivement en lycée professionnel
c'est fragilité là existe plus et que et
donc ça explique notre volonté de
renforcer les moyens pour il sait ces
inégalités donc je vous rejoins sur le
fait que c'est une approche systémique
mais ça explique aussi notre volonté
d'asseoir une effort particulier sur le
lycée professionnel pour accompagner ses
difficultés je vais faire vite mais
présidente mais des savoirs fondamentaux
pour tous selon la réalité des élèves et
selon les lycées professionnels et parce
que vous en avez tous plusieurs sur
votre circonscription on voit que les
réalités sont pas les mêmes que les
élèves ne sont pas les mêmes que les
liens tissés avec les partenaires
économique ne sont pas les mêmes et au
fond c'est aussi cette réalité là qu'on
souhaite pouvoir accompagner c'est de
dire que les équipes éducatives savent
au fond mieux qu'une décision
unilatérale parisienne ce qui doit
pouvoir être engagé dans leur lycée et
donc c'est des moyens qu'on souhaite
pouvoir leur donner et dont ils
disposent pour pouvoir ajuster ces ces
modalités pédagogiques
renforcer mais à la rentrée 2024 je suis
convaincue qu'il faut pouvoir déployer
sur tous les lycées professionnels un
renfort de savoir fondamentaux parce que
oui
l'écart de niveau existent et qu'il faut
pouvoir l'accompagner et le rattraper le
bureau des entreprises c'est une
obligation de résultats je vous rejoins
une obligation de résultats sont des
moyens considérables qui sont mis en
oeuvre et au-delà de ses moyens nous
souhaitons en voir des effets des effets
sur la réussite des élèves en termes de
taux d'insertion des effets aussi sur le
sens que ces jeunes trouvent dans leurs
études et ils vous le disent quand vous
allez en lycée professionnel et vous
l'avez tous fait ici il vous disent
qu'ils aiment aller en stage qu'ils y
trouvent du sens qu'ils ont ils en
comprennent mieux la réalité des savoirs
qui sont dispensés en cours et c'est
donc important de pouvoir mieux lier
l'établissement à la réalité économique
des formations sur lesquelles il
dispense à savoir ça passera par des
indicateurs les indicateurs de taux
d'insertion de taux de poursuite
d'études réussie et de taux de
décrochage et donc oui il y a une
volonté d'avoir des résultats derrière
ces transformations et puis cette
volonté de culture générale que vous
évoquiez nous la partageons également au
travers notamment de la mise en place
d'options par les équipes enseignants il
s'agit véritablement de permettre aux
équipements saignantes d'aller ici
permettre d'aller apprendre une langue
là-bas d'aller chercher les
enseignements sur du codage ailleurs
d'aller travailler sur l'entrepreneuriat
parce que beaucoup de jeunes vous disent
qu'ils veulent être entrepreneurs demain
et donc au fond de permettre aux acteurs
des lycées de déployer des options qui
répondent à ces enjeux de culture
générale qui donne du sens encore une
fois et qui permettent d'accompagner ces
jeunes aussi dans leur citoyenneté c'est
un enjeu très clairement pour moi
d'attractivité du lycée professionnel de
donner aussi ce choix assez jeune et de
donner aussi voilà ce corpus qui permet
aux jeunes d'aller plus loin dans son
développement monsieur le député de Paul
Vanier vous
m'interrogez sur les moyens alors
permettez-moi de réitérer le fait que ce
sont des moyens inédits qui sont mis en
oeuvre sur le lycée professionnel
au-delà du milliard d'euros
supplémentaires par an et donc des 20%
d'augmentation du budget pour le Lycée
professionnel sont donc des moyens
considérables par France 2030 par le
maintien d'effectifs enseignants à la
rentrée prochaine par une augmentation
d'ailleurs de ces équipes qui viennent
accompagner les équipes pédagogiques
notamment en infirmier assistant sociaux
CPE qui sont aussi une nécessité
d'équipe qui doit pouvoir être
accompagnée tout se fera et je me
permets de le redire dans le giron bien
sûr de l'éducation nationale et de la
jeunesse c'est certains voulaient donner
à prêter les le doute là-dessus je le
réitère à nouveau tout se fera aussi
dans le caractère national des diplômes
donc c'est son de détendre des drapeaux
qui n'ont aucun sens nous souhaitons
encore une fois renforcée et les savoirs
fondamentaux et la place de la
préparation aux enjeux économiques de
demain contrairement à vous nous pensons
que nous pouvons allier les deux et que
nous devons allier les deux accélérer la
promesse républicaine de la voie
professionnelle que de savoir aussi bien
préparer ces jeunes à des savoirs
fondamentaux qui feront d'eux des
citoyens éclairés et préparés mais aussi
des citoyens qui soient préparés à un
métier à un avenir professionnel à une
capacité à s'adapter aux évolutions du
monde économique et donc c'est tout là
là tout l'enjeu finalement de cette
réforme du lycée professionnel ce n'est
pas une préparation à court terme
puisque ces jeunes rentrent dans un
cursus et ils en sortent quelques années
plus tard c'est donc une préparation de
ces jeunes pour qu'ils soient prêts à
être armés pour leur parcours personnel
comme professionnel il s'agit de placer
encore une fois le lycée professionnel
dans ces grandes transitions alors si
peut-être vous appelez au statu quo moi
personnellement je crois qu'il faut les
préparer à ces grandes transitions il
faut leur donner cette capacité à se
différencier sur le marché du travail
parce qu'ils seront préparés au grandes
transition celle du numérique celle de
l'écologie celle évidemment des
transitions démographiques je le
rappelle c'est un tiers des élèves et ce
tiers des élèves de lycée professionnel
621000 élèves un quart d'entre décroches
seul un sur deux élèves diplômés sincère
dans l'emploi et seul un élève sur deux
qui poursuit des études supérieures
réussis à obtenir leur diplôme c'est
donc si vous vous appelez au statu quo
pour nous un devoir que de pouvoir faire
évoluer le lycée professionnel qu'il
s'adapte aux enjeux d'aujourd'hui et qui
préparent mieux ses élèves monsieur le
député portier vous avez souhaité
porter au fond une remarque celui de
cette réforme qui est portée pour la
première fois un niveau présidentiel
c'est la première fois qu'un président
de la République porte au niveau
présidentiel une réforme du lycée
professionnel il pendant sa campagne
présidentielle il la porte aujourd'hui
en tant que Président il met encore une
fois des moyens inédits et au fond il
assume parfaitement de dire que trop
longtemps ces lycéens professionnels ont
été invisibilisés qu'ils n'ont pas fait
l'objet des priorités nationales ni des
uns ni des autres et que nous avons donc
laissé c'est jeune lycéens des crochets
puisque les autres être orienté de
manière subie plus que les autres ne pas
réussir à s'insérer professionnellement
ou ne pas réussir la poursuite d'études
qu'ils engagés et c'est donc la toux
l'enjeu faire de cette voie
professionnelle donc je crois que nous
partageons là l'objectif de faire une
voix professionnelle d'excellence qui
soit choisie par ses élèves qui est une
offre de formation qui leur permettent
d'être préparée aux enjeux de demain et
qui soit au fond au lycée professionnel
de choix celui dont l'image a changé
celui qui soit celui qui est
reconnu par société reconnue par les
familles reconnues par les élèves
reconnus par les entreprises et qui soit
la fierté finalement aussi bien des
enseignants des élèves des familles et
des entreprises voilà vous avez souhaité
rappeler effectivement cet engagement
présidentiel moi je souhaite
véritablement insister sur le fait que
c'est la première fois qu'on sent pas à
ce point de cette volonté de lutter
contre le décrochage de cette volonté de
favoriser l'insertion réussite ses
élèves et cette
poursuite d'études qui soit réussie sont
encore une fois c'est une chose
d'entamer une poursuite d'études mais
c'est encore une autre que de lui
permettre de réussir madame la députée
pardon
foleste je suis perdue dans mes fiches
madame la députée foleste vous
m'interrogez sur la détermination des
filières d'avenir et la mobilité des
élèves au fond
déjà je voudrais rappeler que les CAP
lycées professionnels sont bien
concernés par la réforme que d'ailleurs
certains auraient besoin de plus de
temps ce que permettra cette réforme
certains ont besoin aussi de rénovation
forte des contenus de cap et c'est ce
que permettra aussi cette réforme et je
vous rejoins absolument sur le fait que
ces filières en campus des métiers des
qualifications notamment donne beaucoup
de sens beaucoup de campus se sont créés
ces dernières années et ont permis de
donner de la perspective en bac moins 3
jusqu'à bac + 5 et c'était évidemment un
élément de valorisation du lycée
professionnel extrêmement fort que de
permettre ces filières et notamment au
campus des métiers des qualifications
alors France 2030 accompagnera notamment
ces ouvertures de formation comme des
fermetures de formation vont parfois
engager ces ouvertures de formation
c'est des travaux de prospective qui
vont être engagés pour montrer au fond
qu'elles peuvent être les possibilités
sur le territoire d'ouverture de
formation très clairement dans les 10
formations qui au niveau national sont
le plus représenté comme des formations
d'avenir sur les territoires on en
retrouve 7 de manière assez constante
donc on voit qu'il y a là des axes qui
peuvent se dégager sur l'ensemble des
territoires et de manière assez commune
mais il est très important pour moi que
que des territoires puissent aussi
initier parce que la réalité
territoriale le le nécessite des
propositions de création de formation
qui peuvent répondre aux enjeux
économiques
c'est aussi le régime de l'internat que
vous évoquez notamment au travers des
métiers des qualifications qui est
relativement fréquent dans
l'enseignement professionnel plus de 15%
des lycéens professionnels sont internes
c'est des capacités d'accueil pour des
élèves plus éloignés qui sont
importantes puisque 56% des lycéens
professionnels disposent d'un internat
dont le taux d'occupation est loin des
100% puisqu'ils ont un taux d'occupation
en moyenne de 77% et qui peut également
être une réponse pour ces campus des
métiers des qualifications et
l'attractivité de ces formations je
voudrais également répondre à pardon je
crois que je suis sur Fatiha madame la
députée Fatia kellouahashi
vous appelez à une augmentation du temps
de classe et c'est ce que permet cette
réforme notamment par le biais de
sous-groupe par le biais d'options par
le biais d'accompagnement plus
individualisé de ses élèves et j'insiste
beaucoup dessus parce que cet
individualisation elle est importante
pour accompagner mieux les difficultés
des élèves dans les classes en lycée
professionnel sont peut-être plus
hétérogènes encore que qu'on
enseignement général et technologique
mais il ne s'oppose pas encore une fois
et une augmentation du temps en
entreprise nous l'avons ciblé ce
documentation du temps en entreprise sur
la terminale moment où ils sont plus
prêts moments où ils sont dans un projet
qui soit de poursuite d'études ou
d'insertion professionnelle et quand je
vais voir des élèves très clairement ils
nous disent que cela donne du sens
d'être en entreprise que parfois ils y
sentent mieux d'ailleurs mais c'est
important qu'il reste accompagnés à
l'école aussi et c'est donc dans cette
idée là d'accompagner et mieux le projet
professionnel et le temps en entreprise
de manière plus qualitative et notamment
par 12 semaines consécutives en
terminale si le jeune souhaite pouvoir
s'insérer dans l'emploi plutôt que deux
sommes deux fois huit deux fois quatre
semaines pardon pour faire huit semaines
en terminale comme actuellement pour
permettre aux jeunes de mieux s'insérer
et dans l'entreprise et dans l'émission
qui lui sont confiées de se faire une
expérience qui puisse être mieux
valorisée dans son parcours et donc de
lui donner une capacité d'employabilité
supplémentaire voilà c'est formation qui
évolue à cette rentrée vous avez
souhaité m'interroger dessus elles ont
été prises et déjà plusieurs mois et
elle s'accélère rond dans dans les
années à venir elle s'accélèreront pour
accompagner et des ouvertures de
formation et des fermetures de formation
parce que certaines formations ont des
taux d'insertion qui sont très faibles
alors jusqu'à 10% ou des taux de
poursuites d'études qui sont tout aussi
faibles alors que d'autres ouvrent de
véritables perspectives elle
s'inscriront à ses ouvertures et ses
fermetures dans un projet
d'établissement et avec la concertation
bien sûr entre régions et rectorales qui
ont la compétence de cette ou de ces
ouvertures et de ces fermetures de
formation elles se feront aussi dans le
cadre d'un plan mis en place par les
établissements pour accompagner les
fragilités des élèves car de multiples
leviers peuvent être mis en oeuvre pour
accompagner les fragilités des élèves et
permettre une meilleure réussite de ces
jeunes elle s'accélère rond
dès la rentrée 2024 mais je tiens à
préciser qu'il y a plus d'ouverture que
de fermeture et qui donc il est
évidemment important d'accompagner les
enseignants pour qu'ils transforment
avec nous ce lycée professionnel de
demain c'est donc un investissement
encore une fois massif sur la formation
et c'était avec les enseignants que je
souhaite mener cette réforme ils font
déjà des ouvertures et des fermetures de
formation chaque année ils savent
s'ajuster finalement à ses ouvertures et
ses fermetures de filières on continuera
à le faire avec eux comme ils savent
déjà le faire c'est
avec les enseignants et dans avec
cette volonté de créer un meilleur
avenir aussi des enseignants que cette
réforme a été portée elle permettra de
mettre en oeuvre un plan de formation
continue beaucoup plus fort et beaucoup
plus agile pour les enseignants sur
leurs compétences et elles permettra
aussi cette réforme d'accompagner selon
des modalités pédagogiques plus
différenciées parce que enseigner en
lycée professionnel c'est aussi
enseigner à des groupes plus hétérogènes
et donc encore une fois la formation
accompagnera ces modalités pédagogiques
différenciées ces mixité de public
apprentis scolaire mais aussi avec des
modalités pédagogiques plus ajustées à
aux élèves monsieur le député patrié
letus vous avez souhaité
me rappeler et partager avec moi le fait
que le lycée professionnel doit être une
voix choisie que le changement d'image
doit pouvoir être gagné nous partageons
cet objectif au fond nous l'avons fait
sur le sur l'apprentissage et donc je
suis convaincu que nous pourrons demain
le faire pour la voie professionnelle
nous le ferons
en dialogue avec les régions je vous
rappelle que la carte des formations
professionnelles sous statut scolaire et
fixer chaque année par la région avec
accords du recteur pour la rentrée 2023
monsieur le député je voudrais vous
rappeler qu'il est prévu la fermeture de
146 formations
sur les 17000 et l'ouverture de 230
formations la réforme des lycées
professionnels permettra donc d'apporter
davantage de lisibilité sur les
transformations des filières à venir
elle engagera les acteurs dans des
dialogues et des décisions
pluriannuelles et à partir de mars 2024
une carte dynamique des ouvertures et
des fermetures de formation à venir sur
les trois prochaines années sera
disponible pour l'ensemble des
territoires c'est une réponse très
clairement aux enjeux d'urgence
écologique du vieillissement de la
société de la transition du numérique de
la souverain industriel c'est aussi une
responsabilité que nous avons de fermer
des formations qui n'ouvrent pas de
perspective pour ces jeunes dans AFELNET
dès cette année des taux d'insertion les
taux de poursuites d'études sont
affichées connues donc des familles des
élèves pour rendre plus transparent pour
donner une information et un éclairage
sur les choix d'orientation qui sont
faits par les familles et les élèves des
données statistiques sont également
mises à disposition des régions des
rectorats des chefs d'établissement pour
les aider à examiner leur offre de
formation au regard des besoins des
territoires pour les pour les aider à
décider ensemble des révisions
pertinentes ouverture comme fermeture
avec une vision ambitieuse et plus
annuelle
c'est bien sûr avec les personnels de
direction que ça doit se faire et c'est
comme ça que nous le concevons avec
notamment un renfort de formation pour
eux dès cette rentrée prochaine pour les
nouveaux chefs d'établissement et pour
l'ensemble des chefs d'établissement
pour la suite monsieur le député
jean-claudeau je sais votre connaissance
du milieu des lycées professionnels le
pacte et une valorisation très
clairement des professeurs en lycée
professionnel sur la base du volontariat
je me permets de le rappeler pour
l'émission supplémentaires qu'ils
voudront bien prendre des missions qui
répondent aux besoins des élèves que
vous connaissez bien des élèves qui ont
plus de fragilité quand voient général
et technologique pour lesquelles souvent
les professeurs de lycées professionnels
m'ont interpellé en me disant qu'ils
avaient besoin de moyens supplémentaires
qu'ils avaient besoin de faire mieux
avec eux pour pouvoir accompagner ces
fragilités et c'est ce que permet la
réforme mais c'est aussi une
une réforme qui répond à la promesse
républicaine qui est celle de l'école
qui est celle du lycée qui doit leur
permettre à la fois de réussir dans leur
parcours de citoyens qui doit leur
permettre aussi de trouver un avenir
professionnel et c'est ce que permet ce
que prépare la réforme des lycées
professionnels de leur préparer un
avenir professionnel et de ne pas
accepter le déterminisme social auquel
nous nous sommes trop longtemps tous
à signer que nous avons invisibilisé que
nous avons quelque part accepté en
taisant cette réalité et en agissant pas
plus et plus fort le lycée professionnel
il doit aussi préparer aux enjeux
stratégiques préparer aux enjeux
stratégiques ceux de l'écologie du
numérique des transitions démographiques
c'est aussi une des manières de
permettre de placer le lycée
professionnel comme un acteur
déterminant qui vient répondre aux
enjeux de préparation des compétences de
la nation et donc dont on ne peut pas se
passer et c'est pour moi absolument
fondamental que de le positionner comme
un acteur qui permet aux entreprises
d'être d'aller chercher des compétences
bien préparées et qui permet bien sûr à
ces jeunes de trouver un chemin de
réussite madame la députée Sonia
bourreau Ava
voilà je comprends dans votre prise de
position c'est que vous avez
défendu le statu quo le statu quo
finalement d'élèves qui trop nombreux ne
trouve pas d'insertion professionnelle
puisque un sur deux à l'obtention de son
diplôme ne trouve pas s'insérer
professionnellement six mois après
l'obtention de son diplôme vous
souhaitez un statu quo sur les
difficultés qu'ils ont à réussir à la
poursuite d'études puisqu'en sur deux ne
réussit pas à poursuivre des études et à
obtenir ce diplôme vous acceptez qu'un
quart d'entre eux décroche et bien très
clairement nous ne l'acceptons pas et
donc nous avons décidé de d'engager des
moyens considérables pour accompagner
ces jeunes dans la fragilité accompagner
ces jeunes dans leur citoyenneté
accompagner ces jeunes pour qu'ils
préparent un avenir professionnel le
tout dans un caractère national des
diplômes et pour préparer ce tiers de la
jeunesse qui doit avoir un avenir qui
doit être
dans une orientation choisie dans une
orientation valorisée par la société et
c'est pour cela que nous allons adapter
l'offre de formation pour qu'elle
prépare mieux au défi de demain pour
qu'elle les accompagne mieux dans leur
fragilité pour qu'elles ouvrent aussi
des vraies perspectives aux enseignants
pour qu'ils puissent mobiliser leur
savoir-faire en la matière donc vous
[Musique]
pouvez défendre ce statu quo mais en
tout cas nous nous défendrons cet
investissement massif sur le lycée
professionnel pour donner à ces jeunes
les moyens de réussir enfin Monsieur le
Député Lenormand vous avez souhaité
m'interroger sur les outre-mer plus
particulièrement si vous permettez cette
synthèse de de votre question au fond le
fait que bien sûr cette réforme elle
doit s'appliquer aux outre-mer que nous
travaillons en étroite collaboration
avec les recteurs d'outre-mer notamment
au travers d'un plan par exemple pour la
Guyane qui expérimente toutes nos
mesures déjà et qui est qui a un regard
et qui nous donne un regard aussi
particulier sur ces territoires qui
orientent aussi massivement plus
massivement peut-être encore vers la
voie professionnelle qu'ailleurs et
c'est donc aussi par le biais de ces
projets d'établissement par ces projets
de territoire que nous souhaitons
piloter cette réforme c'est pour cela
encore une fois que je ne souhaite pas
une réforme uniforme de la venue de
Paris mais qui se fait à l'échelle des
établissements à l'échelle les
établissements et des territoires avec
des spécificités qui peuvent être
portées tout en maintenant un caractère
national et diplôme j'insiste
véritablement là-dessus mais par exemple
un lycée de la mer fera plus sens
qu'anancy d'où je viens et c'est une
réalité janvier tangible ça ne veut pas
dire que le lycée de la mer n'est pas
intéressant à Nancy mais pour autant
nous avons moins cette filière chez nous
c'est un temps à la fois scolaire et de
formation à la fois un temps
d'entreprise que nous souhaitons
concilier dont la réalité économique du
territoire et donc avec les acteurs du
territoire en force de proposition pour
l'évolution notamment de l'offre de
formation et l'organisation des temps en
entreprise et des temps scolaires il n'y
a pas de suppression de postes je me
permets d'insister là dessus nous
souhaitons faire avec les enseignants
c'est transformation qui sont portées
finalement par les territoires eux-mêmes
pour que nous puissions
donner des moyens aux équipes éducatives
et donner des moyens à ces territoires
pour qu'ils préparent mieux les
compétences entre les ont besoin
merci madame la ministre pour cette ces
premières réponses et
oui non mais vous allez c'est le temps
parce que c'est vrai que c'est une
réforme qui est très importante et que
c'est en effet pour les élèves qui sont
en lycée professionnel ce que vous
portez leur valeur permettent de trouver
ou de retrouver du sens et pour leur
avenir et en fait de pouvoir se réaliser
en tant que jeune adulte et ça paraît
vraiment très très important que nous
puissions vous entendre encore mais pour
ça nous allons avoir une nouvelle salle
de question initiée par Fabrice le
vigoureux pour une minute merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre le
renforcement du mentorat vous l'avez dit
c'est un levier essentiel pour atteindre
l'objectif d'une meilleure insertion
professionnelle et l'insertion ce n'est
pas un gros mot pas une marchandisation
mais souvent une source d'épanouissement
surtout quand un an après leur sortie
d'études un jeune sur deux n'a pas
d'emploi
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre pour soutenir le projet de
chaque jeune l'année de terminale sera
transformée et permettra au lycéens de
passer certaines épreuves plutôt dans
plutôt dans l'année scolaire je
m'interroge sur le bien-fondé de cette
mesure cette restructuration modifie
l'organisation de l'année scolaire et
dégrade d'informations intellectuelle
des élèves de terminale les élèves ne
peuvent donc plus approfondir
l'intégralité des notions clés et
acquérir des méthodes rigoureuses de
réflexion et de rédaction il est
pourtant essentiel qu'il continue
d'avoir une formation intellectuelle
digne de ce nom qu'ils accèdent à
l'emploi directement après ou qu'ils
poursuivent leurs études ils ont besoin
de se former pour avoir un métier vous
savez très bien que beaucoup
d'entreprises n'ont ni le temps ni la
patience de former réellement nos jeunes
par ailleurs pour ceux qui envisagent
une insertion dans l'emploi dès
l'obtention du diplôme la durée des
stages sera augmentée de plus de 50%.
qu'allez-vous faire pour que les lycéens
ne soient pas de la chair à patron ou
seulement de la main d'oeuvre à bas prix
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
Béatrice Piron
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre tout d'abord merci pour votre
présence aujourd'hui en France ces 2,5
millions de personnes qui sont en
situation d'illettrisme vous avez
annoncé vouloir lutter plus efficacement
contre les lettrisme en rendant
universel le droit de savoir lire écrire
et compter pour cela vous travaillez
avec l'Agence nationale de luttre contre
illettrisme l'ancie en tant que cours
président de ce groupe d'études je vous
en remercie vous menez donc des actions
afin de renforcer les savoirs
fondamentaux dans les lycées
professionnels en effet la réforme de la
voie professionnelle propose par exemple
la mise en place d'heures de français de
mathématiques en effectuant en effectif
réduit en seconde professionnelle je
souhaitais évoquer la possibilité
d'utiliser des outils numériques à
l'instar de Tacite solution issues d'un
projet de recherche mené par
l'Université de Rennes 2 destinée au
collège et au lycée qui aide à apprendre
à mieux comprendre non évoquant la
compréhension tacite cette plateforme
accessible en ligne aide les élèves en
difficulté avec la lecture 28%
malheureusement des élèves entrant en
cap et leur permet de prolonger leurs
efforts en dehors des heures de classe
sans impacter de façon significative le
temps enseignant madame la ministre
pensez-vous qu'une généralisation de ce
type de dispositif
Voltaire ou autre sera envisageable
quels autres outils envisager de mettre
en place merci madame la députée Alexis
Corbière
madame la ministre d'abord je vous
propose la question à laquelle m'avait
pas répondu de mon collègue Vanier
allez-vous soumettre ou non votre
réforme au Parlement et à cet assemblée
j'attends la réponse je vous remercie
votre réponse par ailleurs est aussi un
mélange de mesure que je qualifierais
d'inquiétantes et plutôt cocasse cocasse
car vous annoncez la création du bureau
d'entreprise afin je cite de créer un
réseau et un partenariat avec les
entreprises du bassin économique mais
connaissez-vous l'existence des
directeurs délégués des formations
professionnelles qui ont exactement
cette mission à l'heure actuelle donc
c'est assez curieux mais c'est
inquiétant car en fait avec votre mesure
les entreprises auront un bureau au sein
des lycées pro et la grande différence
c'est le président Macron qui nous dit
et vous dites également c'est que
désormais cette tâche ne sera plus celle
d'un enseignant d'un pédagogue ayant une
formation en capacité d'avoir éventué un
regard critique sur l'entreprise mais
celle vous le dites vous-même de
quelqu'un qui vient un acteur du marché
de l'emploi et c'est là que tout le
problème pensez-vous sincèrement madame
alors que tout savons tous que il y a
souvent un Piat encadrement durant les
périodes d'accueil des élèves
actuellement dans les lycées
professionnels que de retirer tout
enseignants et d'avoir uniquement au
regard d'un ancien professionnel pour
avoir du bien à nos élèves pouvez-vous
dire qu'en vérité nos enseignants
faisaient un mauvais travail que ce sera
meilleur demain avec des gens ici de
l'entreprise c'est un métier
d'alignement sur les CFA que vous voulez
mettre pour mon lycée professionnel
merci monsieur le député Emmanuel
Antoine merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre
pour autant nous ne voyons pas très bien
l'efficacité des moyens qui sont mis en
œuvre au service de cet objectif la
solution présentée consiste
effectivement à généraliser le soutien
en petit groupe là où les enseignants
souhaiteraient s'engager cela concernera
les cours sur les fondamentaux ainsi que
le développement de cours optionnels
seconde langue vivante ou
entrepreneuriat mais en même temps avec
l'allongement de la durée des stages il
y a une perte de temps scolaire pour
l'apprentissage des fondamentaux en
enseignement général ces petits groupes
pourraient seulement permettre de
compenser cette évolution surtout il
n'est pas dit que les élèves en
bénéficieront puisque leur mise en place
repose sur l'acceptation par les
enseignants du pacte qui leur est
proposé il n'y a donc aucune garantie
que tous les élèves puissent bénéficier
des dispositifs de lutte contre le
décrochage puisqu'ils sont tous soumis
au volontariat des enseignants avec un
risque de rupture de service public
alors madame la ministre comment
pouvez-vous nous assurer que vous
parviendrez à lutter contre le
décrochage dans ces conditions
merci madame la députée Fabienne Colboc
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre la réforme
des lycée pour ambition de mieux lutter
contre le décrochage scolaire et de
mieux préparer l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes ainsi trois
initiatives sont présentées dans votre
réforme à la mesure 5 ambition emploi
parcours de conciliation et tous droits
ouverts ces dispositifs ont pour but de
prévenir le risque de décrochage pendant
et après le lycée ces mesures
apparaissent comme des opportunités pour
découvrir d'autres voix de
professionnalisation et donner et donner
aux jeunes un élan de motivation dans
l'accomplissement de leurs études
pouvez-vous nous dire Madame la Ministre
comment ces initiatives vont-elles
s'appliquer concrètement comment les
relations avec les structures
d'accompagnement par exemple les
missions locales vont-elles se
consolider dans la durée je vous
remercie merci madame la députée
angélique Franck
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre ma question porte ouverte de 15
500 places en formation de
spécialisation d'ici 2026 je rappelle
qu'au moins de 2% des élèves en
Terminale professionnel en bénéficié
actuellement alors qu'il existe déjà une
trentaine de spécialisations la plupart
des acteurs et les syndicats concernés
pensent que cette instrumentalisation
des lycées professionnels au service des
branches professionnelles fait passer
l'école de la République au second plan
derrière les intérêts économiques à
court terme y a-t-il pas là à risque
réel de créer des sections incerentes
spécifiques et assignées résidence qui
ne formeraient que des exécutantes
territoriaux et qui seraient d'ailleurs
coincé le jour où l'entreprise en
question n'a plus besoin d'eux
côté opérationnel en quels seront les
aides apportées au chef d'établissement
déjà sur sollicité pour leur mise en
place et sur le fond ne pensez-vous pas
que généraliser une année de
spécialisation après le bac ne risque
pas de dévaloriser le bac professionnel
lui-même en le déprofatinalisation
merci madame la députée Laurent Croisier
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre il suffit de questionner les
lycéens professionnels pour entendre que
leurs paroles sont très éloignées des
propos caricaturaux de lutte des classes
de nos collègues députés nups à se
demander si certains ont véritablement
déjà mis un pied dans un lycée
professionnel les lycéens apprécient les
stages en entreprise car ils sont
l'occasion d'appliquer concrètement ce
qu'ils apprennent auprès de leurs
professeurs et les stages sont leur
bouffées d'oxygène moderniser l'offre de
formation en créance 150 nouvelles
filières porteuses d'emploi c'est non
seulement leur portée de la
considération et surtout faire du lycée
professionnel un parcours de réussite
le lycée professionnel n'a pas vocation
à former à des métiers sans déboucher ou
qui seront très prochainement balayés
par l'intelligence artificielle s'il est
bienvenus et légitimes de placer en
priorité l'intérêt l'insertion
professionnelle des lycéens ce
changement suscite à juste titre une
grande inquiétude chez les enseignants
des formations supprimées à laquelle il
s'agira de répondre avec beaucoup de
considérations et des solutions
acceptables je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député car l'olive
bonjour madame la ministre 159000 c'est
le nombre d'emplois supplémentaires que
notre industrie nécessitera d'ici 2030
pourtant 67% des entreprises
industrielles déclaraient l'an passé
éprouvaient des difficultés de
recrutement madame ministre lors de
votre venue au lycée Adrienne Bolland à
Poissy vous aviez pu exprimer auprès des
acteurs de terrain le souci de
développer ou créer de nouvelles
filières pour répondre aux enjeux de
notre économie d'aujourd'hui surtout
celle de demain car cette question du
recrutement est lancinante pour de
nombreux industriels je les cours de mes
visites auprès des différents acteurs
industriels de la circonscription dans
les Yvelines s'élantis à Poissy
Jean-Claude Decaux à plaisir ou encore
storenji à Beynes alors que le Président
de la République a souhaité refaire de
la France un pays industriel il
renforçait notre indépendance et nos
compétences votre réforme du lycée
professionnel devra apporter des
réponses claires et concrètes aux
entreprises et aux élèves et je sais
toute votre mobilisation sur ce poids
aussi quel message souhaitez-vous
adresser à nos acteurs industriels
implantés sur le territoire ou à ceux
qui seraient amenés à le faire et qui
éprouvent des difficultés de recrutement
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député Léo Walter
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mon collègue Paul Vanier a pu
vous dire tout le mal que nous pensons
de la réforme du lycée professionnel
porter votre par votre gouvernement même
si ça déplaît à certains et avec nous
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
des associations de parents d'élèves des
organisations lycéennes et des
spécialistes de l'enseignement
professionnel outre sa philosophie
inique et dangereuse elle est si mal
ficelée que des responsables académiques
étaient obligés de reconnaître la
semaine dernière devant les
représentants du personnel qu'elle
allait entraîner la fermeture de filière
pleine et la création de filières qui
allait sans doute rester vide mais je
voudrais revenir sur les propos du
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
déclarait sur France Info le 5 mai
dernier que les enseignants de ces
filières fermées pouvaient je cite se
diriger vers le professorat des écoles
ou les collèges ma question est donc la
suivante confirmez-vous cette annonce
ahurissante qui dénote comme souvent
chez son auteur une méconnaissance
totale du métier ou allez-vous
travailler sérieusement sur les
carrières de ces professeurs sacrifiés
question subsidiaire qui vous
permettrait de ne pas répondre à la
précédente allez-vous écouter l'ensemble
des acteurs du lycée professionnel et
renoncer à cette réforme
inepte et destructrice je vous remercie
de votre écoute et de vos réponses merci
monsieur le député Maxime minot
merci madame la Présidente je vais
effectivement rebondir sur ce que vous
avez énoncé lors de la réponse aux
orateurs de groupe sur la fermeture
effectivement prochaine des 146 filières
dont vous nous avez effectivement
annoncé il y a quelques instants les la
fermeture il est évident que que ces
annonces ont été
surprenantes ont créé de l'angoisse chez
les étudiants ce secteur mais aussi chez
les chez les professeurs qui en plus de
se sentir méprisé se demande à quelle
sauce ils vont être mangés alors
pouvez-vous
explicitement revenir sur les réponses
apportées aux orateurs de groupe car
personnellement je n'ai pas été rassuré
j'aimerais effectivement connaître
quelles sont les mesures compensatrices
de ces fermetures de filières je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député Sophie
Tellier polian
merci madame la Présidente d'abord
madame la mini je voudrais vous dire que
si nous ne partageons pas l'orientation
politique de votre réforme il faut
arrêter de nous dire que nous sommes
dans le statut quo c'est l'élément de
langage un petit peu facile je pense que
vous pouvez faire mieux donc nous
pensons que c'est vous qui êtes dans le
statut quo pourquoi parce que rien n'est
fait pour changer le recrutement dans
les lycées professionnels c'est à dire
pour changer le problème majeur
aujourd'hui qui est que les lycées
professionnels sont plein des enfants
des classes populaires et points et ça
c'est le vrai sujet dans lequel vous ne
pour lequel vous ne faites rien donc ce
que vous faites c'est effectivement une
certaine forme de statu quo sauf que
cette réforme elle est très favorable
aux entreprises d'abord pourquoi c'est
l'État qui paye
les indemnités de stage des élèves
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui le justifie sans
aucun engagement des entreprises à ce
que la qualité des stages soit plus
importante et deuxièmement pourquoi
est-on sur une évolution déformation
uniquement sur le court terme c'est à
dire les besoins immédiats des
entreprises et pas le moyen terme c'est
à dire les besoins du tissu économique
de notre pays merci madame la députée
Emmanuel Pellerin
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre présent dans tous les lycées
professionnels les directrices et
directeurs délégués à la formation
professionnelle et technologique sont
considérés comme étant la personne
référence en ce qui concerne l'insertion
professionnelle en effet parmi leurs
missions ils doivent développer
fidéliser les relations avec des
entreprises qui accueillent des jeunes
en stage ou en apprentissage
pourtant la réforme des lycées
professionnels prévoit dès la rentrée
2023 la création de bureau des
entreprises dans l'objectif sera
d'assurer la liaison entre l'école et le
monde du travail tâche
occupé jusqu'à présent par ses
directeurs dans ce contexte j'aimerais
savoir quel est le devenir des
directeurs et directrices délégués à la
formation professionnelle et
technologique merci infiniment
malheureusement je ne pourrais pas
écouter la réponse car je dois revenir
en hémicycle merci monsieur le député
Véronique
Géraldine Bannier
madame la mini j'aurais deux questions
très concrètes d'abord une question sur
les postes de recrutement s'agissant des
2100 bureaux des entreprises les
professeurs actuellement relais école
entreprises s'interroge sur la
possibilité pour eux d'intégrer les
nouveaux postes le 35 heures prévues
est-il analysé quid de la prise en
compte de leur ancienneté de leur
progression de carrière est-ce qu'ils
seront payés mieux s'ils s'interroge là
dessus et pouvez-vous nous apporter des
précisions sur ce sujet et j'ai aussi
une question alors là côté élève avec le
sujet des échecs en apprentissage quelle
solution pour ce type d'élève et
notamment en direction des sortants du
Lys pour qu'ils le passage en entreprise
et parfois bien difficile
merci madame la députée Belka belladad
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je souhaite madame la ministre
abordé la question des moyens liés à la
question des 2000 son bureau des
entreprises dans chaque lycée
professionnel ça a été évoqué à
l'instant par notre collègue aujourd'hui
meunier une campagne de recrutement est
en cours la question c'est s'agit-il de
recruter 2100 personnes en faisant appel
notamment des agents actuellement en
poste à l'éducation nationale ou bien de
recruter des personnes extérieures à
l'éducation nationale et comme la
rentrée approche la rentrée prochaine
pouvez-vous nous indiquer madame la
ministre où nous en sommes actuellement
voilà merci monsieur le député Sophie
met
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je tiens à
mettre en lumière les inégalités
d'opportunité qui s'observent entre les
territoires ruraux et urbains les jeunes
des espaces ruraux sont davantage
éloignés de leur établissement scolaire
que les jeunes urbains car ils sont
moins souvent scolarisés dans leur
commune de résidence cette distance
entre le domicile et le lieu d'études
croient fortement lors du passage au
lycée ainsi l'éloignement de l'offre de
formation et les opportunités de
poursuit d'études ou d'emplois tant à
décourager les ambitions des élèves
issus de la ruralité en outre après leur
baccalauréat les jeunes adultes qui
souhaitent poursuivre des études dans le
cadre d'un cycle long sont nombreux à se
déplacer vers des espaces urbains où
l'offre y est plus large le nombre de
bacheliers des territoires ruraux qui
choisissent pour leur part de s'orienter
vers l'apprentissage et plus important
que dans les grandes villes il
privilégie davantage des études courtes
madame la ministre si cette réforme vise
notamment à permettre au territoire de
développer des filières professionnelles
porte uses pour les jeunes que
prévoyez-vous pour enrichir l'offre de
formation dans l'enseignement supérieur
sur les territoires ruraux je vous
remercie merci madame la députée Laurent
est-ce que negox
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre merci de votre présence et pour
ces éclairages qui nous sont essentiels
si j'ai la chance d'avoir sur ma
circonscription le lycée du bois de
Revel très demandé facteur d'excellence
et qui a réalisé le futur trophée de la
Coupe du monde de rugby le lycée
professionnel le plus souvent concentre
des élèves plus fragiles socialement et
scolairement que le lycée général ou
technologique donc là de seconde
seulement 58% des élèves présentent le
maîtrise satisfaisante du français et
seulement 33% en mathématiques si les
mesures cette réforme en été amplement
détaillées sur le premier point qui est
celui de l'insertion professionnelle le
second pilier celui de l'amélioration
des savoirs fondamentaux dépendra
davantage des mobilités des modalités
pardon d'applications notamment du taux
d'enseignant volontaire cette réforme
zéro décrocheur m'a paraît donc
essentiel j'ai entendu vos précisions
quand au soutient que vous allez
déployer vis-à-vis des formations
professionnelles permettant une
poursuite d'études en différence avec
une insertion professionnelle directe il
faut par ailleurs être attentif à
l'écart de plus en plus plus important
entre le lycée général et l'enseignement
professionnel où toutes les ambitions
culturelles sont délaissées et du coup
je n'ai pas de question merci
monsieur le député pour ce témoignage
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
pour répondre à mes collègues
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
vigoureux je sais effectivement votre
engagement de longue date sur le
mentorat notamment au travers du
dispositif tandem pro que vous avez
initié sur votre circonscription et avec
beaucoup de succès cette volonté au fond
elle est de le déployer partout dans les
lycées professionnels sur tout le
territoire le président de la République
avait annoncé en mars 2021 souvenez-vous
le lancement du Plan jeune à mentor qui
est le premier plan gouvernemental en
faveur du développement du mentorat en
France au fond aujourd'hui 150
000 jeunes bénéficient du mentorat en
2022 notre objectif est donc pour les
lycéens professionnels d'aller plus loin
ils sont je vous le rappelle 620 000 cet
accompagnement c'est un vrai plus pour
les jeunes c'est un vrai plus parce que
beaucoup des jeunes de lycées
professionnels je vous le rappelle
viennent d'un environnement social plus
fragile parce j'aime beaucoup n'ont pas
de réseau et beaucoup bénéficient plus
particulièrement encore de cette
accompagnement par un adulte qui vient
les aider à acheminer à réfléchir à
construire au fond leur parcours donc
mon objectif est que chaque jeune qui le
souhaite en lycée professionnel est un
mentor d'ici à 2025 c'est donc
une mobilisation
toute particulière qu'il faut mettre en
oeuvre et vous avez été quelques-uns à
l'évoquer c'est non seulement des moyens
supplémentaires c'est 20 millions
d'euros supplémentaires chaque année qui
va être mis sur le mentorat pour les
lycées professionnels pour que c'est
plus de 600 000 élèves de lycée
professionnel puisse être accompagnés
par un mentor et au-delà de ça c'est une
organisation territoriale qu'il ne faut
pouvoir engager avec
le la mobilisation de tous associations
entreprises fédération et c'est donc
pour cela qu'actuellement je mobilise
tous ces acteurs pour qu'ils puissent
plus largement encore s'engager pour
être et organiser le mentorat en France
organisé aussi cette couverture
territoriale parce que dans tous les
lycées professionnels de France nous
devons pouvoir répondre à cet enjeu
d'égalité des chances et accompagner
finalement par la richesse des
expériences des adultes ces jeunes dans
des conseils d'organisation
d'orientation de carrière de vie au fond
et donc cette mobilisation elle est là
et demain elle doit être encore plus là
je mets emploi et donc des moyens
supplémentaires accompagneront également
la mobilisation des acteurs pour cela je
voudrais apprendre à Madame Paulet sur
l'organisation de l'année de terminale
cette année de terminale qui engage donc
une réorganisation et une augmentation
des durées de stage pour les élèves qui
souhaitent s'insérer professionnellement
je le rappelle aujourd'hui en terminale
ils ont deux fois quatre semaines
organisées en deux temps demain ces
jeunes ne feront pas deux fois quatre
semaines pour ceux qui souhaitent
s'insérer dans l'emploi mais une fois 12
semaines enfin de parcours de formation
il s'agit au fond d'une mesure assez
logique si je puis dire à la fois de
donner un temps de stage qui permet de
déployer des compétences dans le cadre
d'une mission qui permet aussi à des
jeunes de faire leurs preuves et
peut-être d'être embauché par
l'entreprise puisque il le fait enfin de
parcours on le retrouve d'ailleurs cette
idée de stage de fin d'études dans
d'autres niveaux et je pense par exemple
au Master 2 qui est une mesure j'ai
envie de dire assez logique de liens
entre l'école et l'entreprise et qui
permet aux jeunes au moment où il a eu
le plus d'enseignements de pouvoir
déployer les compétences qu'il a
acquises dans l'environnement
professionnel et de faire ses preuves
donc c'est là une mesure j'ai envie de
dire de bon sens une mesure aussi
d'accompagnement du projet de l'élève
s'il souhaite s'insérer
professionnellement et c'est au fond pas
un choix sur les enseignements
fondamentaux parce que c'est aussi
la reconquête du mois de juin que
souvent on évoque et que nous ne faisons
pas tellement donc c'est un vrai enjeu
pour nous d'aller réemployer ce temps du
mois de juin vers du stage et vers le
tremplin vers l'emploi c'est si je le
rappelle si le jeune le souhaite aussi
du temps du mois de juin qui est accordé
à la préparation de la poursuite
d'études parce que là aussi nous
souhaitons mettre en place tous les
moyens pour lui pour lui faire réussir
la poursuite d'études si elles sont
choix
madame la député Piron je sais votre
engagement sur l'illettrisme qui est
fort et absolument nécessaire je le
rappelle le niveau de maîtrise et savoir
fondamentaux lecture écriture calcule
dans les lycées professionnels les plus
faibles que dans le reste des
établissements de la voie générale et
technologique est dû à des difficultés
plus importantes des élèves qui ont plus
de difficultés d'ordre social mais
également parfois de handicap et qui ont
eu un parcours scolaire plus difficile
et qui ont des position de ses savoirs
qui sont parfois plus difficiles ces 2,5
millions de personnes en France en
situation d'illettrisme soit 7% des
personnes ayant été scolarisées en
France
âgées de 18 à 65 ans on voit que cet
enjeu-là il est majeur notamment dans
les journées défenses citoyenneté on
identifie 9,6% de personnes en
difficulté de lecture parmi lesquelles
4,1% en grande difficulté ce constat je
crois que nous ne pouvons simplement
nous en satisfaire et le constater et
qu'il ne faut donc agir cette réforme
agit en ce sens par l'accompagnement des
élèves par des professeurs qui sera donc
renforcés par des classes à effectif
réduits qui seront plus nombreuses par
des professeurs plus nombreux aussi à
intervenir pour aider ces jeunes à
surmonter leurs difficultés mais nous
allons également doter les équipes
enseignantes d'outils plus performants
pour mieux accompagner ces jeunes et
c'est un travail que nous réalisons avec
l'agence professionnels de lutte contre
l'illettrisme pour travailler à
plusieurs objets concrets le premier le
développement d'outils qui permettent
d'identifier plutôt dans le parcours et
plus systématiquement les situations
d'illettrisme des jeunes pour
accompagner mieux ces jeunes bien sûr
ensuite de après ce recensement pour
mieux mettre en visibilité ceux qui en
ont besoin d'une offre de formation plus
adaptée et enfin de créer plus largement
un observatoire de l'illettrisme qui
permettra de suivre plus précisément les
effets de nos politiques publiques dans
et hors des établissements scolaires
madame monsieur pardon le député
Corbières une réforme du lycée
professionnel qui vous le savez a été
engagé dans le dialogue par l'ensemble
des parties prenantes que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure plus de trois mois de
concertation avec l'ensemble des 160
participants à ces groupes de travail
qui à la fois se fera de manière
réglementaire mais dans le biais de par
le biais de nombreuses concertations ça
fait c'est troisième fois que je viens
devant l'Assemblée nationale pour parler
de cette réforme et qui se fait
également avec les directeurs délégués
des dfppt vous évoquez tout à l'heure il
s'agit au fond d'organiser un réseau et
les ddfppt auront demain une animation
d'un réseau de ces charges de relation
entreprise qui au sein des
établissements accompagneront les
missions qui sont les leurs je tiens à
le rappeler qui sont nombreuses
d'émissions des dfpt qui sont
ambitieuses et qui doivent pouvoir être
accompagnés par un réseau qu'ils animaux
donc au sein de chaque établissement il
s'agit véritablement encore une fois de
valoriser ce lien avec les entreprises
d'organiser mieux la réponse des
établissements aux enjeux de
partenariats d'actualisation des
compétences de mise aussi en lien avec
des élèves avec les entreprises pour les
aider à trouver des stages et être au
fond aussi le bureau du réseau des
élèves qui n'en n'ont pas
madame la députée Antoine donc souhaité
m'interpeller sur la lutte contre le
décrochage c'est une des priorités de
cette réforme et malgré le travail de
qualité qui est réalisé par le service
public de l'éducation sur 100 élèves qui
rentrent en seconde professionnelle un
tiers va décrocher sans bac ou
équivalent je crois que sans nous
attaquer au décrochage c'est au fond la
première bataille et que nous que nous
ne
mènerions pas c'est donc absolument
essentiel que de viser ce zéro
décrochage et
identifié par le Président de la
République ça se fera d'abord en
améliorant l'orientation parce qu'il
faut susciter des vocations si on
souhaite faire de la voie
professionnelle une voix choisie c'est
aussi avec l'action donc de papel Ndiaye
auprès des collégiens qui pourront dès
la 5ème avoir une découverte des métiers
dès la rentrée prochaine pour mieux
identifier les formations de la voix
professionnelle c'est aussi notamment
c'est aussi en intensifiant
l'accompagnement des élèves lycéens
pendant leur scolarité et on les
valorisant davantage que nous
parviendrons à réduire ce décrochage et
c'est enfin en mettant en place des
filets de sécurité anti décrochage à
toutes les étapes du parcours pendant et
après le lycée professionnel donc au
travers des dispositifs que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure tout droit ouvert
ambition emploi et les parcours de
consolidation c'est clairement un
objectif de lutter contre le décrochage
de des jeunes à toutes les étapes du
parcours d'enseignement pour ces lycéens
professionnels madame la députée callboc
vous avez souhaité nous interpeller sur
la lutte contre le décrochage tout droit
ouvert sera donc mis en place dans tous
les lycées professionnels dès la rentrée
2023 c'est un dispositif qui permettra
aux équipes éducatives de proposer vite
une palette de solutions adaptées aux
élèves en fort risque de décrochage
grâce à une mobilisation de l'ensemble
des acteurs susceptibles de les aider
dans le lycée et hors du lycée le
principe est clair et simple pendant une
période de quelques semaines jusqu'à un
trimestre tous les droits leur sont
ouverts afin de trouver la solution la
plus adaptée c'est-à-dire que ces jeunes
conservent la possibilité de retour dans
leur lycée dans leur statut scolaire et
les droits qui leur sont associés ça
leur permet également de cumuler avec
des droits associés les solutions
externes qu'il teste par exemple en
termes de rémunération si la solution
testée youvre droit pour les lycéens de
moins de 16 ans tout droit ouvert
s'appuie sur le parcours aménagé de
formation initiale le Pachy qui existe
depuis 2015 au sein de l'éducation
nationale et qui est ouvert des 15 ans
madame la députée angélique Ranque je
rappelle le caractère national des
diplômes et le fait que cette réforme
s'inscrit pleinement dans le caractère
national des diplômes je réponds je
rappelle aussi que pour répondre aux
besoins des entreprises et permettre une
meilleure insertion des élèves 10.000
places en formation de spécialisation
après un bac pro sera créé dès 2024 et
20000 places en 2025 que les chances
d'insertion dans l'emploi de ceux qui
ont suivi une spécialisation bac + 1 et
augmenter de 20 points et que cette
spécialisation est une demande forte des
élèves comme des entreprises elle permet
au lycée de se spécialiser dans un
domaine et de multiplier leurs chances
d'être recrutés et puis pour les
entreprises d'entrer en contact avec ces
jeunes qui ont une vocation à devenir
demain de futurs candidats au
recrutement aujourd'hui il existe une
trentaine de mentions complémentaires
différentes permettant une
spécialisation des élèves après leur
baccalauréat professionnel aujourd'hui
elle bénéficie à plus de 4500 élèves
demain ce seront plus de 20 000 places
qui seront donc ainsi créés pour 2025
madame monsieur pardon le député
Croisier vous appelez à mon attention
sur les stages qui sont effectivement
appréciées pour des pour des élèves qui
sont parfois peu scolaires si je puis
dire qui ont envie de donner du sens à
leur parcours de scolarisation très
clairement c'est effectivement une
réalité qu'on rencontre lorsqu'on se
déplace dans les lycées professionnels
et au fond je partage avec vous l'idée
que on ne peut pas se satisfaire de la
situation actuelle que l'offre de
formation doit être repensée pour mieux
accompagner en profondeur ces jeunes
dans une dans un parcours de réussite
que le stage donne aussi des conditions
de réussite par le sens qu'il donne à
ces jeunes aux enseignements qu'ils ont
par l'expérience qu'il leur ouvre et
qu'il leur permet de valoriser
lorsqu'ils sont en recherche d'un stage
plus important ou d'une insertion
professionnelle c'est donc là toute la
place qu'on souhaite donner au stage
notamment en terminale lorsque le projet
et l'insertion professionnelle poste bac
ou poste cap c'est important de pouvoir
accompagner le projet de l'élève et de
répondre aussi à ses aspirations c'est
important pour nous aussi de valoriser
ce temps en entreprise notamment par la
gratification des stages dès la rentrée
prochaine de 50 à 100 euros par semaine
de stage réalisé donc soit jusqu'à 2100
euros pour un élève de baccalauréat
professionnel si il fait tous les stages
et qu'il vise une insertion
professionnelle c'est une reconnaissance
c'est aussi une responsabilité que de
considérer cette en entreprise comme des
temps
d'appropriation aussi des enseignements
fondamentaux qui leur sont dispensés
monsieur le député car l'olive vous avez
souhaité m'interroger sur au fond la le
message que je pourrais porter aux
acteurs économiques et le lien
finalement qu'on va faire entre enjeux
économique place des territoires et
réalité des besoins des territoires de
nombreux défis sont à relever dont
l'urgence écologique le vieillissement
de la société les transitions du
numérique l'indispensable
réindustrialisation de notre pays la
voie professionnelle doit être au coeur
de ces enjeux là doit apporter une
réponse assez enjeu de de compétences
pour la nation et c'est donc tout le
travail qui va être engagé autour de la
transformation de la carte des
formations et qui est engagée de manière
cohérente entre l'État les préfectures
les régions académiques et les académies
la collectivité région bien sûr et les
établissements chacun de ces niveaux
doit être ainsi acteur de la
transformation de la carte des
formations initiale de façon à proposer
qui mène à l'emploi dans les territoires
c'est un travail qui est conduit avec la
région avec une stratégie d'évolution de
la carte des formations professionnelle
qui dessine à l'échelle académique en
concertation avec les régions mais qui
doit rentrer aussi dans une
caractérisation aussi de la réalité
territoriale à l'échelle des bassins
d'emploi et en lien avec les acteurs et
les entreprises c'est tout le sens de la
méthodologie que je souhaite porter pour
cette évolution de l'offre de formation
en lycée professionnel
monsieur le député Walter vous avez
sauté m'interroger sur les ouvertures et
et fermeture je rappelle que les
fermetures représentent 146 formation
que les ouvertures représentent 212
ouverture et plus de 80 ouvertures via
France 2030 c'est 4000 places qui sont
concernée par
les ouvertures enfin si en 2600 places
d'ouverture
c'est donc dire que la place du lycée
professionnel demain doit être renforcé
nous considérons que le lycée
professionnel a toute sa place pour
préparer les compétences de la nation
qu'elles ne le fera que si elle forme
les jeunes en leur ouvrant des
perspectives et que c'est
mentir à ces jeunes de les laisser
rentrer dans des formations dont on sait
pertinemment qu'il n'ouvre ni
perspective de poursuite d'études ni
insertion professionnelle réussie
monsieur le député Maxime minot vous
m'interrogez sur
là aussi les ouvertures et les
fermetures je rappelle que donc nos
farmons 146 formations sur les 17000 que
nous en ouvrons bien plus encore que
cette
objectif d'ouverture de formation ils
vise aussi d'accompagner les transitions
professionnelles autour de ces 212
ouverture de formation nous souhaitons
accompagner les grandes transitions et
que les jeunes de lycée professionnels
doivent pouvoir être présents
écologiques numériques démographique que
ces jeunes ont leur place dans la
société de demain et que c'est important
qu'il puisse eux aussi être préparé à
ces enjeux nous accompagnerons bien sûr
les professeurs de lycée professionnel
qui connaissent déjà des ouvertures et
des fermetures de filières chaque année
le dialogue engagé entre les régions les
rectorats constatent le besoin en
évolution des formations et donc chaque
année un certain nombre de professeurs
sont déjà accompagnés vers des créations
de nouvelles filières et des fermetures
d'autres filières nous renforcerons les
moyens en formation et nous avons besoin
de la mobilisation des enseignants et de
des enseignants pour accompagner laisser
transformation et c'est pourquoi par le
BI notamment du plan France 2030 nous
travaillerons un vaste plan de formation
continue madame la députée
polluant pardon si j'écorche votre nom
c'est donc bien la valorisation de la
voie professionnelle que nous visons
avec un renforcement encore une fois des
moyens sur la voie professionnelle au
travers du pacte au travers de la
gratification des stages au travers du
lien avec France travail au travers de
l'engagement sur le mentorat mais
également au travers du nombre
d'enseignants qui sont dans la voie
professionnelle et des personnels qui
accompagnent les enseignants je pense au
CPE infirmier assistant sociaux qui
aussi accompagne mais c'est aussi un
investissement qui va être fait sur
notamment le choix d'orientation parce
que je vous rejoins pour que le jeune
s'engage et finalement donne du sens
aussi à son parcours cette question du
choix d'orientation de la découverte des
métiers dès le collège pour qu'il puisse
un choix d'orientation éclairé le moment
où il doit faire un choix d'orientation
est essentiel c'est donc tout le sens du
projet porté par PAP N'Diaye sur la
découverte des métiers dès la 5ème 5ème
quatrième troisième pour permettre un
choix d'orientation éclairée au moment
où le jeûne doit choisir sa voix madame
monsieur le député pèlerin vous
m'interrogez sur les dvfpt cette
directeur délégué aux formations
professionnelles et technologiques qui
sont les conseillers au fond technique
du chef d'établissement sur l'ensemble
des sujets liés aux enseignements en
technologie et professionnels leur
mission s'en vastes elles sont elles
vont de l'organisation des enseignements
professionnels à la coordination et
l'animation des équipes
enseignants aux enseignantes au conseil
au chef d'établissement en matière
d'offre de formation de l'établissement
aux évolutions techniques technologiques
mais aussi budgétaires à la formation
personnel ainsi qu'à la relation avec
les partenaires font demain le ddfpt
prend un rôle pivot encore plus
important puisqu'il viendra
soutenir c'est chargé de relations
entreprises il viendra organiser
l'animation de ce réseau pour que nous
allions plus fort encore sur l'animation
de ces quatre grands domaines de mission
que j'évoquais à l'instant en effet
l'enquête Ipsos réalisé en 2013 à la
demande de la DIDP auprès d'un
échantillon significatif d'élèves de la
voix professionnelle a révélé que
72% des périodes de formation milieu
professionnel sont trouvées par le
propre réseau de l'élève ou de ses
parents et quand on sait les fragilités
sociales et souvent les difficultés de
réseaux qu'ils ont on voit à quel point
avoir un bureau des entreprises et
quelqu'un qui accompagne ces jeunes dans
cette recherche de PFMP est essentiel
pour ces jeunes c'est donc un véritable
pôle d'appui auprès du ddfp tel que nous
organisons notamment pour accompagner
ces jeunes et l'évolution des formations
dans l'établissement ainsi que des
relations avec les entreprises la seule
députée Belkhir Belhaddad se bureau des
entreprises il a donc pour mission cette
relation de partenariat avec le tissu
économique ce travail sur l'organisation
des enseignements professionnels cette
coordination et cette animation des
équipes enseignantes ainsi que le
conseil au chef d'établissements en
matière d'offre de formation de
l'établissement une campagne de
recrutement et lancée elle permettra à
des personnes en interne de l'éducation
nationale comme en externe de candidater
assez assez fonctions ce sont donc des
fonctions administratives 35 heures par
semaine et qui donneront donc un contact
pour les partenaires entreprises toute
la semaine sur chaque établissement avec
un contact dédié qui permettra ce
meilleur lien entre entreprises et
établissement madame la députée mette
vous avez souhaité m'interroger sur
notamment la capacité d'avoir une action
plus territoriale une réponse
territoriale
aux besoins de formation et aux familles
notamment issues dans de la ruralité
pardon c'est sur tous les territoires
que l'offre de formation doit se
déployer et je vous rejoins pleinement
là-dessus pour les jeunes qui feraient
toutefois le choix de suivre un parcours
de formation non présent à proximité de
leur domicile l'internat peut leur
permettre d'accéder à ces formations je
rappelle que le régime de l'internat il
est relativement fréquent en lycée
professionnel près de 15% des lycéens
professionnels sont internes et les
capacités d'accueil d'élèves éloignés
sont donc importantes puisque 56% des
lycées professionnels disposent d'un
internat dont le taux d'occupation est
loin des 100% puisque 77% en moyenne
d'occupation et constatée c'est
important qu'il puisse y avoir les deux
une offre de formation de proximité mais
également la capacité à accueillir ces
jeunes en internat lorsqu'ils souhaitent
poursuivre des études qui ne sont pas à
proximité de leur domicile et évidemment
accueilli dans de bonnes conditions pour
qu'il puisse réaliser leurs études de
manière sécurisée et bien accompagnée
madame la députée Bannier
vous avez souhaité m'interroger j'ai
peur de d'oublier quelqu'un c'est bien
ça je suis dans le bon ordre
j'ai oublié quelqu'un oui non madame
Banier
ensuite à Monsieur esquine gokes
j'ai mis mes bêtises sur sur pardon
l'échec en apprentissage et au fond
qu'elle accompagnement je rappelle qu'un
jeune sur quatre rond son contrat
d'apprentissage avant son terme c'est un
chiffre qui n'est pas acceptable qui est
peu qualifié aujourd'hui parce que on
sait pas bien ce que devient le jeune
est-ce qu'il retrouve une autre
entreprise etc donc on a besoin de mieux
identifier ce phénomène mais pour autant
c'est un vrai sujet sur lequel nous
devons travailler et c'est pour pourquoi
j'ai fait de la prévention du décrochage
d'une priorité de la voix
professionnelle parce que aujourd'hui
trop de collégiens confronté à des
difficultés scolaires sont orientées
vers la voie professionnelle et que trop
de jeunes décrochent du lycée
professionnel pour ces raisons-là nous
souhaitons sécuriser les parcours des
jeunes leur permettre lorsqu'un contrat
d'apprentissage est rompu quel que soit
l'origine de de cette rupture sûr
employeur ou jeune qu'il ne soit plus
synonyme d'arrêt du parcours de
formation et c'est notamment la raison
pour laquelle la mixité des publics en
lycée professionnel est encouragé cette
mixité elle permet d'accueillir dans des
mêmes classes de même établissements des
élèves ou des apprentis et elle permet
donc de rapprocher ces deux voies de
formation scolaires et apprentissage au
sein des lycées professionnels et
permettre aux jeunes d'évoluer dans leur
projet soit en cas de rupture du contrat
d'apprentissage de revenir en voie
scolaire ou au contraire de permettre à
des jeunes qui souhaitent aller vers
l'apprentissage de le faire c'est
important aussi de rappeler que cette
dynamique là je pour la poursuit aussi
plus largement sur l'apprentissage dans
une volonté de travailler sur la qualité
de l'apprentissage et c'est là l'objet
de concertation que que je vais engager
avec les acteurs pour que nous puissions
travailler partout à un meilleur
accompagnement des apprentis et à une
diminution très nette de ce taux de
rupture
voilà en quelques mots et en dernier
lieu
monsieur
coxès
clairement voilà votre votre témoignage
nous confort dans le fait que clairement
le fait de travailler en filière est
essentiel pour l'attractivité aussi des
lycées professionnels être pris dans un
dans un consortium
d'acteurs de la formation dans des
filières qui permettent dès le bac moins
3 jusqu'au bac + 5 d'évoluer mais aussi
avec des partenaires économiques qui
reconnaissent les acteurs de ces de ces
filières comme performant dans la
préparation des compétences dont les
acteurs économiques ont besoin c'est un
facteur essentiel de l'attractivité de
du lycée professionnel de le placer
comme un acteur à part entière et de
qualité pour préparer les compétences de
la nation et donc je vous rejoins
pleinement sur le fait que travailler en
filière est essentiel et PLA au lycée
professionnel comme un acteur
fondamental dans cette filière les tout
autant je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre pour toutes ces
réponses donc moi je vais encore
conserver mes collègues quelques
instants puisque nous avons avant de
nous séparer nous devons désigner un ou
une rapporteur sur le projet de loi
relatif à la restitution des biens
culturels et on fait l'objet de
spolulation dans le contexte des
persécutions antisémites perpétrées
entre 1933 et 1945 comme vous le savez
ce projet de loi a été adopté par le
Sénat la semaine dernière et si nous ne
savons pas encore quand exactement il
sera à l'ordre du jour de notre
assemblée mais je souhaite que nous
soyons prêts le moment venu donc il m'a
semblé judicieux de nommer leur
apporteur dès aujourd'hui et de fixer
son examen aux commissions mercredi 21
juin donc j'ai reçu la candidature de
Madame Fabienne Colboc et s'il n'y a pas
d'objection elle est désignée rapporteur
il n'y a pas d'objection félicitations
Madame Fabienne Colboc vous êtes désigné
rapporteur et nous nous retrouverons
mercredi de la semaine prochaine le
matin pour la présentation des rapports
d'information sur l'avenir de
l'audiovisuel public et l'évaluation de
la loi pour une école de la confiance et
l'après-midi pour la Table Ronde des
représentants syndicaux des enseignants
sur cette même réforme du lycée
professionnel mes chers collègues je
vous remercie et je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine